[Music]
young jamie
back in the [ __ ] saddle how you
feeling
very well thank you covid free four days
in a row now i've kicked it
yeah and now uh you still can't taste
anything
well you look at that come back today
but yeah like five percent taste
yeah it's gotta be pickle juice doesn't
even taste like anything really it just
tastes like water
whoa very weird but you don't have any
residual symptoms nothing wrong all good
can breathe everything
you know good to see you back a little
worried about you thanks a little
worried about you
not worried about you alex jones
this is the most anticipated thing i
ever did i've probably had no
exaggeration
two or three thousand people in the last
year and a half asked me when are you
going back on joe rogan and i'm always
saying i don't know i don't know and
then i learned
you were moving here like three four
months ago and now we're here and this
is this is exciting
i don't get uh butterflies anymore but
i've actually have them here and this is
this is great it's good to
have butterflies after about 20 years
didn't get the last two times i was on
didn't get it when i interviewed trump
didn't get in a lot of things but i've
got butterflies here today
and tim [ __ ] yeah i'm just a
kid in a candy store
thank you thank you for making this
dream come true
this is what i've always wanted to do
and we've made it happen this is my
make-a-wish i can die happy well i'm
happy you're here yeah i got my fridge's
lane shirt because i believe all women
is that how you say it it's i think so
yeah i thought it was gallane
i thought it might be it's gizzling
do you know look at me no galen it's
just lame gizzling
that's a ridiculous name yeah her father
was a famous
uh mi6 massage spy that reportedly used
sex operatives to control people he died
being thrown off a yacht
in the middle of the atlantic ocean and
of course she
uh got caught in that farmhouse on the
east coast and she was really the pimp
over
epstein in a giant sex network ring over
scientists
that they were compromising uh so they
can control not just government but
industry and science and so
that was the master blackmail operation
they were running and her sisters are
big in tech
like isabelle maxwell she has sisters
that are in
u.s tech companies and i think two of
her sisters uh
were part of the creation of magellan
which was that big search engine like
really so yeah they are a very powerful
family and they have all kinds of
different operations yeah her dad was
the biggest publisher in
england and also the biggest owner of
private tv stations in england
and uh when he died it turned out he was
a front basically for intelligence
networks
now let me right off the bat say you
were telling me about epstein and this
island
years ago you were telling me long
before
anybody would i think you told me about
him
before his first arrest a long time ago
i talked about how they have these
islands they they fly they compromise
children but i learned all this from ted
gunderson
20 plus years ago he was in line to be
the fbi director
he was the head of the fbi in los
angeles he was a very famous fb
uh agent even ranco intel pro it's a
civil rights movement he apologized for
that before he died
uh in the 2011. but
he came out and he was the one that
explained to me about how they use these
these blackmail rings elements the cia
uh and foreign intelligence groups and
and how they would
basically make people have sex with
children to be part of these
clubs and these cults they were setting
up so i knew about all this from ted
gunderson were they young girls
that did they tell them these girls were
underage or did they look like they were
older
like like this uh the borap movie
where they uh yeah
if you haven't seen it it's very
disappointing because they set him up i
saw it
they did set him up but nothing happened
they made it look like
giuliani was jerking off in front of
this girl he was taking his mic off
he would have to be the biggest savage
on earth to jerk off
in that situation and they also said
that he inappropriately touched her back
when he touched her back i am not
exaggerating it was like this right it
was a couple of light taps on the back
while she was close to him taking off
his mic thing he goes
oh thank you very much dear and he goes
yes i just need your name and your phone
number
and then she takes off his mic and then
he leans back
and he's tucking his shirt back because
he just pulled the mic out right but
he's lying on the bed to do it now
if you're an old man and i'm sure he's
probably got a bad back
like that's probably how you would do it
but any of us that have had to put the
mics
on our side and then you put it in your
pants up your shirt and then you've got
it gets to be
you've got to get it out that's what you
do but but it's worse than that
remember when he was playing the who was
the gay character he played like 10
years ago
bruno bruno yeah remember congressman
ron paul the time was
had run for president and he's in the
hotel he goes oh the light broke please
step into this room
so there's no chair ron paul sits down
and he's read the newspaper
and bruno comes in and pulls his pants
out and says i wanna have sex with you
now that would be sexual assault if that
was a man to a woman ron paul pushes him
out of the way goes out of the room
and so this is what he does he's done it
to other people it's his specialty
is to say you're being interviewed
listen let me just before we go any
further i [ __ ]
love aaron cohen genius i think he's
brilliant i think he's amazing
but his interpretation of what happened
in the room with rudy giuliani it's it's
not accurate
in my opinion well listen i mean and who
is american
he's tapping her while she's touching
him
and removing his mic he does this little
tap on her waist
but it's not creepy it's like an old man
like a little tap tap tap
right like if if you want to take it out
of context like i don't know
if there's more to it than well let's go
further let's go further
right after this happens uh barat
sashmir cohen runs in in panties and a
bra saying have sex with me he's 15g too
old yes so this is and giuliani's like
what did that i'd have a heart
like what is this listen my [ __ ] 12
year old sense of humor loved it
yeah but the thing about it is they're
making it seem like giuliani was jerking
off in front of her yeah and that's not
like
he lies back and he's tucking his pants
like if can we show the whole thing so
we can look at it
we don't have to they put it on his
promotional material
but they put this out as promotional
material to be promoted
they put it out on twitter the clip is
on miss pat's give a shout out to mrs
pacquiao jamie's technically
it's on her uh instagram if you want to
but let me drop a bomb show on you joe
okay a bombshell no no i've been a big
fan of sasha barraco until i learned he
spoke at the adl
last year and called for my arrest
for free speech and he called for jeff
zuckerberg's arrest
uh for mark zuckerberg's arrest so he
called for my arrest
and and for mark zuckerberg's arrest for
free speech
he wants to work in hollywood right you
got to do what you got to do but let's
go further deals
agreement i mean he said arrest people
for their free speech
and he supports internet censorship so
how does he make his money being this
avant-garde cutting edge
really uh you know over the edge comic
that does things that could technically
be seen as illegal i support his free
speech and then he says i don't deserve
it well it's really dangerous
he's flawed like many great artists yeah
you know i mean i i'm
until they come for him he's not gonna
understand the slippery slope of
censorship and
you know this is another thing that you
know people
have uh people have criticized me for
being friends with you
and for talking to you and they also
criticized me for not supporting
a lot of these people that got banned
and de-platformed my take on it has
always been
the best way to counter wrong speech
is correct speech right when someone
says something
that's wrong or someone says a
conspiracy theory that's not accurate
the best way to counter that is is to to
do
better speech to have people say the
accurate information
and to let the truth rise to the top
when you start
censoring people the problem is it's a
[ __ ] slippery slope and there's a
reason why we've been so steadfast
in supporting the first amendment in
this country and people think it doesn't
apply to tech
because these tech institutes are
private businesses and they should be
able to do whatever they want with their
private business
the problem is that [ __ ] slippery
slope has gone
from censoring you from banning alex
jones off twitter a year and a half ago
to getting the white house pr press
secretary banned off twitter
because she posts something from the new
york post which is crazy
it's crazy it's cr that's a 200 and
whatever you're old america's oldest
newspaper
and the and what she said the the post
what the what they put printed and put
out there is accurate
well let's go further let's go further
they're denying
that that it's a real story but they
don't ever say the emails are fake
they just say it's a smear no it's a
real laptop the videos have been
released
it's confirmed but just think about this
it is a smear in that they're trying
they're putting it out there
they're they're timing it sure but
they're not denying they're not denying
it's real no it's real
it's real how did the laptop how did
this laptop become this big story that's
where it gets tricky yeah i'm curious
because
supposedly he dropped it off at
a laptop repair shop in delaware what an
idiot i mean who's
drawing that well crackhead right right
the guy's smoking i keep forgetting he
smokes crack well he did at the time
apparently he's kicked it so
congratulations to him
but the the guy who had some problems no
this is self-admitted and and also they
have the receipts
and they here's the thing he calls him
dozens of times
everybody knows when you bring a laptop
or anything and they say if you don't
pay for this
we're gonna wipe it and sell it and so
three months goes by six months goes by
nobody ever comes and gets it the guy
goes to look at it at the repair shop
the owner
and there's all these 25 000 files what
looks like underage girls
and all the rest of this crazy stuff and
him smoking cracker god knows what
he gives to the fbi ray does nothing the
director hides it from trump
and so people let's just say inside that
had copies of that
they leak it to rudolph giuliani who
then now has started to put it out so
instead of
instead of facing up to it they just say
anyone promoting this
whether it's the house or senate
committees that we're linking to it or
the new york post or the president's
press secretary you're now banned which
again shows it's
it's election meddling it's gatekeeping
to cover this up but i'll tell you what
else has come out now
his daughter biden's daughters uh
uh purportedly reportedly and they've
not denied it now this broke three days
ago
left her diary in a house that she had
rented and the diary talks about
all the same stuff and everything and
what that is
when i was looking into this the thing i
keep seeing people say is that he lived
in california he lived in california
that is true that's what i keep reading
but they fly back and forth to delaware
i mean
these are jet setters they fly to
ukraine that also might make sense that
that's why you didn't go back to
delaware to pick up the laptop
because when you're cracked out in
california it's really hard to make the
flight
all right right i don't know i don't
know so tim is the only one here
it's not an easy flight coming down off
cocaine or crack yeah have you smoked
crackers
no i have free based cocaine which is
basically yeah it's close how close is
it
not not as close as where i ever went
made shady deals in the ukraine
well that's never done that by the way
that's in the emails that's in the
emails
finally where it's like yeah i need 30
million part of it goes the big guy
they're like okay we want to meet with
your dad and there's photos of them
meeting
and playing golf so let me tell you this
is real the fbi has the files
they admit it's real it's a big deal but
it's a real problem to ban this stuff
from twitter
putin rejects donald trump's criticism
of biden family business
well because it's russia's bribing
hunter biden 3.5 million through putin
through the moscow mayor who he's
friends with to hunter biden again
well if i was putin i would deny it too
listen putin has got to
love this if i was putin sitting back
right watching these [ __ ] people eat
themselves alive and destroy the first
amendment
destroy democracy yeah that's great i'm
sure
they have a hand in it i'm sure china
has a hand in it i'm sure
iran has a hand yeah this is what the
intelligence communities
have been telling us for a long time now
is that it's not just
one foreign company or foreign country
that's trying to
[ __ ] with our democracy yeah the idea
that the russians have a monopoly on
this
no i mean if the russians were an nfl
football team they'd be like the lower
third
the u.s and china are the top teams
right and we should say we should say
the united states does it too sure it's
100 confirmed
the idea that russians got trump in is
asinine because
here's what happens notice they tried to
impeach trump just nine months ago
for stuff in ukraine because whatever
they are worried about
they project okay so trump doesn't have
russia connections
trump doesn't have of those connections
trump doesn't have
those outside connections you can't buy
him he doesn't have lobbyists
the problem is he then has family and
people around him
that basically become lobbyists for
themselves and trump isn't really even
aware of it
and then that's going on and i mean even
junior aids now
you'll find out how people give in to
millions of dollars
just to say something to the president
is this standard [ __ ] is this just stan
how politics have always been done it's
just now we're seeing it well
it was standard let's say 200 years ago
that you'd go out for the wife or the
brother or or somebody that works at the
white house
it got organized the last hundred years
with lobbyists trump literally cut the
lobbyist off
but all it did was now make everyone
around him a lobbyist no they're not
officially a lobbyist how did he cut the
lobbyists off he just stopped meeting
with him and stopped and just said i
want briefings on what's going on i'll
decide
so that's why he pissed official
washington off not that he's even
perfect but that he actually became the
president
sort of making decisions himself instead
of having consortiums and lobbyists pay
him for policy
that's why he says bidens raise more
money than me of course i can call up
all
these companies they'll give me any
money i want but i gotta do what they
say but it would put him in a
compromised position yes but i'm being
honest about it the vacuum and
and the the blind spot is that then
everyone around him in his cabinet and
everyone that works there even down to
mid-level people
are now getting multi-million dollar
contracts for companies
like at t and stuff just to just to just
to even
mention something of the next hold up
before you any further you said att
has it been proven that it's a t or are
you just saying att
like companies like let's just say i'm
not saying atg is bad i think atg's
overall good company but is att doing
something bad
no i just i was mentioning that as a
fortune 500 company
okay but it's not 18t no it's not agency
so we shouldn't say that
see this is why you need someone that's
like a fact checker right now no
no slow down the media will say i'm
wrong
right about that but okay okay but no no
hold on his personal lawyer
his personal lawyer the one that ended
up going to jail actually michael cohen
michael cohen was getting money from att
go ahead and pull it up i mean i was
just trying to give you a gestalt
question
but i just want to i've told you before
what you really need on your show is
like a
a legit journalist who's right next to
you with a laptop going ah alex hold on
hold on
just slow down but i think you're right
about that because but you get so much
right but when you get something wrong
that's important
att confirms it paid trump lawyer
michael cohen's company
yeah now i remember that see joe yeah
they're always saying
that i'm making sure that they're lying
right right now every once in a while my
memory used to be photographic but from
everything i've done it's not as good as
it used to be
it moves really quick okay so what i'm
saying stuff is just
data knowledge okay and then i can like
okay yeah did i say that yeah it's real
check it out
but i'm not trying to make stuff up 99
of the time here it is att confirmed
tuesday evening that paid president
trump's personal loyal michael cohen
in 2017 for in quotes insights into
understanding the new administration
[Laughter]
insights i love that um so how much they
pay them 200 000 bucks and four separate
payments of 50 bucks
in late 2017 early 2018. interesting
yeah but he got paid i think the number
was 10 million total
from a a handful of companies but by the
way t
did it shady look avenatti alleged that
essential consultants a shell company
set up by cohen before the election to
pay stormy daniels was paid by several
corporations including
a t at the time att was seeking
government approval for its acquisition
of time warner cnn's parent company it's
a
dirty world yeah but i'm telling you at
t is a sweetheart compared to google
and facebook and twitter and all these
people so i wasn't attacking them
i was giving an example of how everyone
in his entourage
becomes a a lobbyist because he thinks
i'll just cut lobbyists off he's not
taking any money
and but then everyone around him becomes
a lobbyist that's why you worry about
the influence that people like jared
kushner have because i know
a lot of biggest uh his supporters again
coulter who's trump's biggest supporter
goes
i don't love the idea that he hired his
children and that they have a lot of
connections i can tell you this
i can tell you this people were really
pissed who were patriots the
intelligence community
in other areas but also enemies of trump
that kushner had so much influence
but now kushner's gotten a lot of
respect uh because he's actually gotten
a lot of huge peace deals done that
nobody
else could do for 50 years now
interesting how little press
those piece deals is they're getting
none press yeah it's really concerning
so so now i mean they were pissed like
who's this kid and now everything he
touches turns to gold but he looks like
the omen we've covered
he looks like a little little devil it's
just like yeah and he's paid he paid
twice what it was worth
for like 666 park avenue oh jesus christ
that's not good
that's not great wow that's not great
why would he want that
i think it was more than twice look up
666 is it park avenue or listen maybe he
says it's funny
maybe he's a satanist he's getting good
deals done in the middle east yeah i
mean
he's playing good deals they say the
antichrist gets good deals in the middle
east
if you're gonna be a luciferian at least
make peace in the middle east how about
that maybe satan's the only one that can
do that
att is a really good cell phone company
yeah right hey
hey just the way it works i mean you
wanna when i mentioned att it's an
example that popped in my head of an
unofficial lobby well i was happy that
we called you on it because then we
found out it's correct
yeah look you've been correct about a
lot of [ __ ] this is my point
from jump i found out about agent
provocateurs from you
from your 9 11 road to tyranny video
where they use them at the world trade
organization protests in seattle in the
late 90s
like i had no idea that it was a common
practice
to send in masked people to start
smashing things during peaceful protests
right so then they could go
i could give you the straight dope on
antifa you wanna do that go ahead
okay yeah hold on a second 666 park
cavity project
have been a black hole of cash for years
until a sovereign wealth fund made a
substantial investment for the property
after kushner
was already serving as trump's top
advisor in the white house
wow okay might be a nice building
though what does it say the kushner
company is that what is the company's
yeah
the kushner company's 666 park avenue
project
that's hilarious i think that's
beautiful his dad went to prison for
i believe setting up his brother with
like a prostitute
yeah yeah what yeah that's they're a fun
family the customer wait a minute wait
wait the dad set up the brother with a
with a prostitute with a call
okay step by step we're going to
fact check every one of those no no no
this is well known
but we need to have this for the people
like me and alex don't you spout off
i have the facts i know you have the
facts but i want to make sure chris
christie jared kushner's father
committed one of the most loathsome
disgusting crimes i prosecuted wow
wow we fact check all of that is crazy
make that bigger for my old eyes look at
this
what does it say according to the ex
purpose in the book were published by
axios and the guardian
christie claims the younger kushner was
behind his departure from trump's inner
circle
after 2016 election writing that he was
still apparently seething over the
events that had occurred a decade ago
well what is the events of a decade ago
they over prosecuted his dad he should
have gotten like
uh he should have gotten probation for
trying to set up his brother with a
hooker said he got a bunch of time
imagine your dad setting you up with a
hooker it's crazy he's
trying to shut the other family member
up here's here's what uh
if my father is guilty i would mr
kutcher pled guilty
he admitted the crimes christy said and
so what am i supposed to do as a
prosecutor i mean if a guy hires a
prostitute seduced to sue
his brother-in-law oh it's his
brother-in-law what he said his
brother-in-law his brother-in-law
okay i got confused and then videotapes
it and then
sends the videotape to his sister to
attempt to intimidate her from
testifying before a grand jury
do i really need any more justification
than that holy [ __ ] but it wasn't to
intimidate that's his interpretation
that stuff goes on divorces all the time
people go videotape the other person
cheating so
that's why it was wrong he went to
prison because he wasn't doing it he was
doing that to show that the person
testifying was wrong
of course you're trying to influence
testimony with the truth it's this idea
that
yes they're cheating i told you they
were here's the proof how does that
become
fraud okay i'm confused so he set up his
brother-in-law
with a prostitute to show that this was
been going on before which he'd already
alleged
okay as part of the plot kushner hired a
prostitute to lure
shoulder into having sex in a
bridgewater new jersey motel first of
all if you find yourself in a
bridgewater new jersey motel you're
[ __ ]
run as the hidden camera rolls
a tape of the encounter was then sent to
kushner's sister
and uh shoulders i know the whole story
so
just trust us we try we're just i just
made a comment that
you start thinking about like who's
running the [ __ ] these stories and
hunter biden's running around with
you know underage people on the laptop
you start going why does everyone work
for ukrainian gas company like
who are these people running the country
the west controlled ukraine so they just
use that
as as the money laundering off it's not
the ukrainians running right
they use it as that but let's expand on
this joe what i'm getting at here is
i didn't bring up att they're a good
company overall they're not the one
censoring and stuff
okay it's the big tech the reason i
raised that was just the one that popped
my head the first one
it's massive what's going on i was just
being honest that trump's trying to get
a couple hundred grand
like i mean as much as that sounds like
a lot of money but the bigger ones like
he's talking about communist china yeah
amazon
communist china is even bigger it's
bigger than big tech it literally spends
hundreds of billions of dollars buying
us off it owns hollywood
it owns a lot of the big telecoms it
owns the majority of our debt
and i've got articles in the la times
and new york times i brought for you
where they say xi ji ping must destroy
trump to save america
he was our leader and then at the davos
group he said three years ago i will
destroy trump
i will work with hollywood i've got all
his quotes right here and jiji pink said
i want to overthrow american democracy
i want to repudiate it i want to
discredit it and gigi ping admits he
admires adolf hitler
and joseph stalin okay but isn't he
doing that
because that seems crazy yeah you can
pull it up i understand i'll show you
step by step isn't he doing that because
it trumps trade deals
like the trade deals that trump wants to
do with china
are not nearly well they're not
one-sided for for him here's what
happened
special interest in the u.s went in and
opened up china you know in the 70s when
most of them didn't have running water
or electricity
they're hard working smart folks but by
one sided trade deals where we
we have higher tariffs on them and they
on us and all the rest of it are vice
versa
through those deals they use the slave
labor of china to then take over
manufacturing worldwide
and so china's a client state of the
globalist and so now
the washington post the la times the new
york times i brought you the articles
here
dreams of red emperor the relentless
rise of xi ji ping and it says
in these articles he must destroy
american western christian values we
love him
and we accept china as our master i have
the goddamn articles
but this is treason the freaking dude
right here washington post
uh but who's saying that quote who's
that quote here i'll give them to you
this is this is the washington post
and there's a huge article la times i
understand but the quote that you just
said about he must destroy
just like i said at t gave money
unofficially lobbying and you pulled it
up
i read the article i'm not giving you
that i understand what you're saying but
what i'm what i'm asking you is who
you quoted someone but who did you quote
when you said that i'm quoting
from when i read these again this
morning before i came here what i
remember
david don durie durley oh that guy
and and uh this this chinese lady i
think he's talking about the prevailing
sentiment of what they
feel they must understand but you quote
somebody it's best no no no no no no
i just said in these articles right well
look at the headline
g's choice destroy trump or save them
from weakened america i mean
right she needs to destroy trump the
chinese dictator needs to destroy our
president so do you think that they're
doing that because
trump wants to change the trade deals
you know what trump said trump didn't
start a trade war he ended our surrender
we have been surrendered for 40 years
with china
where they don't take our goods but we
take all of theirs and they manipulate
their currency but we haven't
manipulated ours where we have carbon
taxes that obama put in
to shut down over half our coal plants
that are clean and our electricity
prices went up where you could not run a
factory here
competitively against china so when joe
biden says we're going to cut off all
the fossil fuels not just fracking right
if you did that we wouldn't just go
bankrupt we'd start to death
75 of our power comes from fossil fuels
i understand
let's step by step again are coal plants
really clean
100 percent clean how is that possible
i'll tell you please okay
there's two different types of major
power when they say when he says clean
coal i roll my eyes every time
when trump's like clean coal clean well
that's because the engine is
so damn good is it i'll tell you please
they had old-fashioned coal plants china
doesn't have one scrubber or filter on
their coal power plants
and china doesn't have clean burning
coal there's one place in the united
states that has major deposits of coal
that is such pure carbon you don't even
need scrubbers
nothing comes out but carbon dioxide and
water well they know we know water is
not bad so they list carbon
dioxide people think it's monoxide just
like in studies if you say
the scientific name of water most people
in penn teller skits on the street will
say ban dihydrogen monoxide
if you go out on the street joe rogan
and ask 100 austenites
dihydrogen monoxide is everywhere if you
get too much of it you can die
ground and most people will say i want a
band of hydrogen monoxide that's the
scientific name of water
same thing if you do the scientific name
assault sounds scary well
so so hydrogen monoxide
is the bad one hydrogen dioxide is a
good one that's the life cycle
on earth there's there's light there's
water there's
oxygen and there's carbon dioxide those
are the four things you've got to have
for
for life and so they've gotten people
convinced
to say coal is dirty it puts out carbon
dioxide and water vapor
and so until about the 70s we were still
burning
dirty coal full of mercury all of they
found huge deposits
of clean burning coal out west enough in
utah around the whole world for over a
thousand years
what's the difference between the coal
like well let me tell you okay please
one coal is so damn pure and it's only
in the united states and major deposits
that basically you don't need to put
scrubbers on it but our scientists in
the 40s 50s 60s and 70s
because they realize that dirty coal has
mercury in it has all these horrible
toxins they put scrubbers on it that's
when you drive by a coal plant it's just
big huge buildings and
wires and and hoses and big huge steel
looks like an alien spaceship
that's because it's called distillates
they know how to burn it and then take
off all the chemicals all the toxins and
make plastics and make chemicals and
make pesticides
and make everything else that comes out
of that and then out of the stack
comes nothing but water sensors on it
nothing but water and carbon dioxide
totally clean totally pure so so that's
what's going on
so carbon monoxide is what everybody's
worried about
carbon dioxide increasing and the
environment has
no negative effects let's talk about it
they've done they've done ice core
samples
okay all over the antarctic and the
arctic they've done mud core samples uh
in in
all over the world but mainly in siberia
and whales for some reason jamie i hope
you're googling
i i haven't got some decent stuff to
pull up but he's
got yeah better right now so so so what
happens is
they they can go back twenty thousand a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
years at least in the ice
and they know that they've also done
spectrometers in the stone
they can scan until it was there carbon
dioxide was over 500 times
stronger in the time of the t-rex okay
in the jurassic age that's why plants
grew so fast things were so big
there was a higher oxygen level just
like mars lost its atmosphere
used to have an ocean they've now gone
and proven it lost its atmosphere as a
smaller planet couldn't hold it truth is
the earth's losing its atmosphere
so what's crazy is we come right along
at this time pump up all
of this juice and all this carbon that
was produced on the surface with plants
and animals that ran down and cracks
into the earth
we're now pumping out all that carbon
saved for millions years ago
and actually terraforming the planet
putting more carbon dioxide in that we
actually need
right this time like aliens figure this
out but hold please but hold please
isn't carbon dioxide responsible for an
increase in the temperature of the earth
but they said that we would have a seven
increase they said that by 2013 all that
la would be flooded and new york would
be flooded all that's lies
okay but let's forget about what they
said in the past what they're saying
now is that carbon dioxide increase
is responsible for an increase in the
temperature of the earth which which
which we hope it does
because we hope it increases the
temperature the last ice age
hold up but hold on but the increase in
the temperature of the earth is
responsible for the increase in
hurricanes
the frequency and the power of the
hurricanes if you look up this
the spectrum in the last hundred years
hurricanes have gotten weaker that's all
media hype but let me just tell you
oh jesus joe joe joe i swear to god i
swear to god i can prove all this to you
this is so easy for your audience
are you a carbon dioxide salesman listen
well they always say i'm getting my
world companies i'm not
but can i please tell you what's going
on yes please do
you are a carbon-based life-form let me
show you what i came here with in my
notes
i have right here in my notes the
carbon conspiracy and that is
specifically
what i wanted to get into here with you
in my notes because this is
everything are you a climate change
denier well see imagine
imagine how that's how they use that
term right are you a climate change
denier it's like a 911 denier right no
the towers got blown up
our government had prior warning and
have been funding al-qaeda and all that
came out later in senate reports
and the 28 let's not go there just now
because we're going to go down around
that
that's true but let's go to carbon i
have that that agree with you there okay
what are you what is what is what is
what is joe rogan made up out of
carbon okay-based life-forms we are
literally stardust
what are your song right exactly what
are trees made out of um
[Music]
tree stuff carbon carbon yeah but
carbon-based life forms it's mostly the
whole planet and so
this is the carbon cycle this is in the
mainline textbooks i understand
so so just like they they they come out
and assault reality now and say
a little boy is biologically a girl i
don't care if he grows up once being say
he's a girl rabbit hole let's not go
down
but i'm saying it's not science they go
the science is settled there's not two
genders
okay hold on let's not go down that road
will you want to go to that road in the
future we will
right now i'll do it let me just i want
you to talk about carbon i don't know i
don't want to get off track
because isn't there a delicate balance
with the temperature on earth and the
rising sea levels and the melting of the
ice caps
this has all been established by a lot
of they say they say the science is
settled
but very concerned environmentalists
have said that an increase in the
temperature of the earth could be
disastrous
power civilization power grab are you
sure it's a power grid i'm absolutely
freaking literally but how do you how do
you know that it's not
all how do you know that because they're
arrogant and they've all written white
papers on it that i've read and i can
give you
white papers yeah it's not what you see
in the news they're called white papers
and joe just like joe this is why people
get banned
from the internet this this these kind
of conversations
we better ban it right now let's not ban
it
i'm just not i'm throwing that out let's
just certainly not bend the don't
listen to new zealand fantastic by the
way
what your youtube page thank you let me
tell you this right now
it'll be up for another day they have
called in the european union
for the arrest of scientists that
question
the cause of anthropogenic warming or
image man-made
okay but there is a contributing factor
scientifically
it's been proven that increased carbon
dioxide
has an effect on the temperature of the
earth do you agree with that
it depends on the models they use
sometimes actually more carbon dioxide
can cause a cooling effect but generally
could cause a
heating effect it depends on potash the
atmosphere volcanic
ejections at the time and also solar
maximum and many
minimums sunspot activity is the main
generator of planetary
climate but the wide if you had a a
giant swath of scientists that are
examining
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere would
you agree that the majority of them
believe that it's a contributing factor
to warming
joe it's a mantra where they say the
majority of scientists agree
that climate change is caused by humans
i agree with climate change
the only thing that's constant is change
of course the climate's changing
what i'm telling you is carbon dioxide
was
50 to 500 times depending on the time
period
higher millions of years ago yes it is
now right but that's
but you also realize that that was what
we got hit by now here
what do you think the motivation is for
them to present the evidence in this way
like you said this is a fraud and
everything what because i've heard you
talk about this before
um what do you think their goal is by
linking all of this climate change to
man-made activity
what's the goal the goal is to
centralize world government that can
then monitor all carbon and control it
as a toxic bad thing
your carbon it makes you bad that didn't
work so now it's oh you have a cold
you're dirty with covent we've got to
track you and control you so the new
thing is covered to cut the carbon
footprint
before we go down the covert rabbit hole
there the environmentalists are not
in bed with the industrialists the
environmentalists are
they're not in bed with all these people
that think that they can
control the the world actually bp and
exxon mobil and others the biggest
funders of the climate change movement
they're the biggest funders of it
contrary to what you hear how so
all right joe here's the thing i
understand this is and you're a smart
guy
and i understand you want to go over
each piece of this let's go through well
we have to we have to agree let's go
through each piece but but understand
you understand that the way you talk
and i enjoy the way you talk fast but
the way you talk is fast and you go on
these long tangents
and you go to frogs being gay and a lot
of things happen
i wanted people i'm putting a record out
yes but i want to do it step by step
let's do this let's do this let's do
this but most people the vast majority
here we got here
bp commits 100 million to fund new
emissions reductions projects
well let me just go back for a second
okay i appreciate you backing me up yes
let me break down are frogs gay
you want to get to the frog stuff now
connect it all
that is by the way why do i feel like
i'm stoned and i haven't smoked me pot
yeah i
wish if he's not gonna smoke it i'm
gonna god it's sober october i have
six break the goddamn rule and then go
an extra day i cannot
i cannot i'm like george washington well
on election night we're gonna get
hammered right mm-hmm
election night i'm getting hammered but
you're gonna i'm gonna pop in
you'll you can pop in but we've told
everybody now that we're doing a live
stream no no we're not
kyle yeah kyle kalinski that's tim
dillon yeah
me al shawn's gonna pop in live it's
gonna be fun
it's live so while you're watching the
world burn live
yeah all right joe here's the here's the
thing it's just like
at least funny to you because i love you
dude it's just like when you said what's
the att deal and i went oh look it up
but but listen we did look it up and we
found this is information this is bigger
okay
let me let me get my brain focused here
for a minute let me just try to explain
i've literally interviewed probably
sound exaggerate 200 top scientists
from petroleum geologists
astrophysicists
to astronauts to quantum mechanics
to petroleum buckle up because i have
two i know [ __ ] i know
okay you're a [ __ ] yeah they're not
yeah trust me
joe you're a smart guy and i'm not
that's his cover he is smart
oh yeah right yeah yeah right i'm a
smart [ __ ]
yeah right okay let me tell you what's
going on i'm going to say it again
you can go to any major study just type
in
carbon dioxide levels were hundreds of
times
higher in earth's early past well i
understand that but also i understand
you can look at the ocean models then
yes even with the ocean models right
and it's true the oceans did cover more
than it is jones human beings weren't
alive 65 million years ago and
the environment wasn't compatible for us
we put out a fraction well we hadn't
developed yet
right well we were moles we had yeah
shroosh
shrews yeah but my point is you're right
yeah is that is that
last time co2 was this high humans
didn't exist the last time there's as
much carbon dioxide
co2 in the earth co2 levels are far
higher now than they have been for any
time during the past
and oil a single co2 milk who can re
remain in the atmosphere what'd you do
oh i see i understand oh okay okay um
so let's let's just go to what this says
and what is this uh paper that's uh
is this a climate central.org okay
the last time there was this much carbon
dioxide that earth's atmospheric modern
humans didn't exist
mega two sharks probably oceans blah
blah blah all right
we as we near the record for the
highest co2 concentrations in human
history 400 parts per million
climate scientists worry about what
where about excuse me about where we
were then
and where we're rapidly headed now
according to the data gathered by
loa observatory in hawaii dope spot the
ppm mark may briefly be exceeded this
month when co2 typically hits a seasonal
peak
sure and i've had scientists on i've had
climatologists talking about the keeling
curve i can tell you all this threshold
according to ralph keeling the
researcher
carbon dioxide is the most important
long-lived global warming gas
and once it's emitted by burning fossil
fuels it helps us
keep our atmosphere hold please hold
please but once it's emitted by burning
fossil fuels such as coal
and oil a single co2 molecule can remain
in the atmosphere for hundreds of years
global co2 emissions reached a record
high
of 35.6 billion tons in 2002
excuse me 2012 up 2.6 from 2011 carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases warm
the planet
by absorbing the sun's energy and
preventing heat from escaping back into
space
which means it enhances the atmosphere
right but the sea levels didn't go like
they said
well aren't they melting but it's a al
gore said by 2013
al gore okay joe but listen this is one
guy's take
brother out there flying around i know
you found a guy admitting that used to
be higher than it is now
i'm telling you it used to be way higher
than it is now this is
right but then the asteroid hit the
yucatan killed all the dinosaurs and
changed the entire atmosphere
i don't want to of the planet with a
dark winter yeah which is
very bad for everything caused by
atmospheric dust for a long [ __ ] time
one major volcano like mount st helens
they estimated
put out more dust than decades of human
uh
dust yes and and human dust is what
helps cause nuclei to form to cause
storms so we are affecting our
environment but most of the
astrophysicists
and most of the physicists i've talked
to most of climatologists i've talked to
they have broken down that the sun by
magnitude
is 98 of the driver
of what happens that's why when the sun
spots take place that's an
a uh huronal ejection from the sun
and one of those shoots radiation in our
direction it'll be clear blue sky but
but they know
when we get hit by that it hits our
magnetic field
and causes an ionization of the
atmosphere and electrification of it and
so that causes the giant storms
so the main driver of climate is the sun
and i think everybody
didn't be a scientist to know what's the
main thing that earth
living off of the sun the sun and so and
so they're telling us that carbon
dioxide does this
what happens is carbon dioxide goes up
they said can
be in the atmosphere for hundreds of
years it's normally absorbed by plants
immediately
who they've got studies they have found
giant crocodile skeletons from just 10
000 years ago
in the central sahara where hundreds of
square miles
is nothing but dunes ten thousand years
ago it was
it was lush jungles and beautiful but
they had goats
and they ate all of the plants and well
there's also the younger driest theory
of asteroid impacts that they they ended
the ice age
12 000 years ago yeah ten well two
impacts i believe there's 12 and then
somewhere but the answer is we don't
know and and so they've now looked at
all these big models
saying it's all carbon dioxide and it's
not it's the sun
it's asteroids it's tectonic it's
electromagnetic from the earth's core
yes
but isn't co2 emissions the one thing
that we can control
so human-created global warming gases
like co2 emissions if we can put a cap
on that
wouldn't you agree let me ask you a
question we don't but if we continue
to put that stuff in the atmosphere and
it continues to get higher and higher
and higher levels of co2 in the
atmosphere wouldn't it that's going to
make it's going to make
the studies show it's going to make
deserts become green again
and plants are going to absorb the
carbon what studies are these
you can look them up okay let's find out
and that's why the left even says
but if you're going to say something
like that and i'm not arguing with you
but if you are going to say something
like that
that's that's a very bold thing to say
you should probably
not just say look them up there should
be something let's type it in let's type
in there's hundreds of them
like actually brought like over 250
articles right here do you have
something that you've read that makes
you so confident that you can say this
uh i actually know what what what the
plant studies show
where in greenhouses they grow plants
with hybrid
higher carbon dioxide and plants can
grow up to three times faster
they live longer of course plants let's
expand carbon dioxide what do they put
out more
oxygen well this one thing that has been
proven is there's more plants
now than there have been at a long
phosphorus there's a global greening
happening yes
countering us losing our atmosphere up
until this point
the earth has less atmosphere than it
did a million years ago and it's like
god did this or something where we
discovered all this oil which is blind
luck that we are terraforming the planet
back
to an earlier healthier state by taking
ancient carbon
that was under the ground and putting it
back into the atmosphere but isn't the
problem that
along the way we're also increasing the
temperature of the planet and we are not
aligned with a higher temperature
we don't know we don't know but in 1963
the club of rome came up with a limits
to growth plan and they had models and
actuaries and i have copies of this in
my film end game
seminal film it's free online in-game
blooper global enslavement predicts a
virus released to lock things down
everything's still happening
because it's their own documents and in
in the 1963 limits to growth club of
rome plan they said we believe there'll
be a global ice age
by 2020 because the last ice age ended
about 12
000 years ago and we're set for that
we're going to tell the public
that actually carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
is bouncing solar radiation off the
earth
because we've seen volcanoes cause this
darkening effect in freezing
so we believe our scientists believe
that carbon dioxide is going to make the
earth
freeze by 2020 and so we've got to have
a global regime to take control
of all the factories and all the energy
and put a tax in for global government
in the name of stopping the ice age
then by about 1987 they went actually we
think it's going to heat up instead
so they flipped the the the propaganda
ask anybody you know
okay but don't you understand that
science back then
didn't have as much data as they have
now so their their models
and what they had predicted in 1963
is faulty compared to the information
they have just like falci said 2.5
million would be dead
from kelvin it was 200 000 but worldwide
what is it
a worldwide tuberculosis killed 20
million people 1.4 million here last
year but nobody
was killed yeah well coveted killed a
lot of time he killed a million
worldwide
what not even a million worldwide no is
that true
yup come on yup well how do we know oh
we use you in models again they're
they're our boss since when did the who
say the lockdown has to go on now they
go oh we're against the lockdown
your nation states that it's their fault
because they know millions are starving
to death
that is true and very underreported yeah
the who has now come out against
lockdown saying that
the reaction can't be a worse effect
than the actual disease so let me back
alex up with the climate changes like
they're
they're they're certainly you know we're
contributing to man-made global warming
but also what are you going to do what
are we going to do i don't know what you
know i mean that's another question
what are we going to do why does his mic
sound weird is it he's hot is he on it
or is it
how i'm hearing it i'm hearing like a
breakup of his mic
sounds good to me that's fine to me yeah
that's weird
okay i'm sorry it must be me jamie's
really low you sound great he sounds
good yeah
okay what is the climate control cause
that's very interesting like the idea of
using climate to con because as you said
with covid and we talked about this
we give up a lot of rights right in the
name of chronovirus exactly
look there's real issues we don't really
know what's going on they want to be
able to track
all carbon and tax it with a ai
surveillance grid with a social credit
score over it yeah and they admit all of
that
joe they tell us okay i understand that
but you do you understand that the
environmentalists who are concerned
are not there's a giant
amount of them that are legitimately
concerned that we're ruining the earth
i understand the greenhouse effects
fossil fuels i understand a greenhouse
effect but these people the reason why
they're acting the reason why they're
trying to get people on electric cars
and trying to get people off the fossil
fuels
hold up please they're they're
legitimately concerned like i don't
believe that these actual
environmentalists sure i agree with you
but i mean here's the deal the new
hummer looks the new hummer looks badass
here's the deal here's the deal but i'm
not getting one because i don't
contribute to global warming
did you make sure you don't want to
contribute to go listen be serious did
you know
did you know that on average more carbon
is spent
for electricity into a car than 93
octane gasoline
well i would believe that because i
would think it it it takes a lot to make
a [ __ ] electric car
but once no no no that's no no no
transmission lines
you lose up to behalf of transmission
and most of it's coal powered brother
so most per megawatt it's more it's
more so i'm plugging my tesla in and i
think
because that's how i like to think i'm a
good guy i'm plugging my tesla in
i'm helping save the world i'm not
because i'm contributing to
power no you're driving you're
contributing to putting
putting carbon dioxide back in and
oxygen and re-terraforming the planet
you're doing a badass job the biggest
energy guzzlers
electric cars are bad ass they are
putting out more carbon than anybody
yeah they don't come out the tail pipe
they come out the power plant top
okay but i love electric cars yeah
team carbon carbon how do you feel about
carbon okay how do you feel about
nuclear power
i absolutely hate it why do you hate it
isn't it clean
94 joe i'm not trying to tear you up
don't tear me up i don't know anything i
told you i'm a [ __ ] no no no no i used
to be for nuclear power
oh what happened i actually did research
what research did you do
um they're always saying it's totally
clean no problem
but then you can look at the u n zone
numbers which i believe international
atomic energy agency
look this up cbs news 94 of nuclear
plants are leaking at dangerous levels
look this up
pause jamie 94
of nuclear power plants are leaking at
dangerous levels
isn't the problem that we're using old
tech like yeah
now you see you're smart yeah much cause
you always know everything joe the
average power plant age is 36 years
almost all these power plants are the
life is 20 to 35 years
fukushima was already a decade old it
was supposed to be a general electric
model
using plutonium radioactive leaks found
at 75 percent of u.s
nuke sites yeah it's worse than that
it's 94 percent
okay well that's not that's not good i
don't know why 94 doesn't pop up out to
the but
wouldn't it be possible with innovation
that they currently have
access to yes yes yes but you talk about
corrupt companies i don't
listen if people actually ran these
right and
the executives here's an example bp i
think oil is great has toxic problems we
should clean it up we should find
alternatives there's all sorts of clean
energy we should go to that you know
isn't
solar is great whatever they've got
fission fusion a bunch of stuff coming
down
take one of the best films out there
because it's so accurate because i had
lawyers on from
i read the transcript of the trial the
uh event horizon
with with bp they literally have all
these degree engineers out there
and bp calls them up from england to
houston and says
you're spending 25 million dollars a day
on this super deep experimental whale
we've decided to not pour concrete they
call it mud in on top this
the executives say we'll save 25 million
dollars a day
if you dump water and all the engineers
went we have mathematical equations just
like water boils at a certain amount
okay we have a certain number of
chromosomes this is fact yeah and they
on record go
you're fired if you don't order them to
dump water into it
so they follow the order dump water in
for five days and it blows up
because water didn't have enough
pressure to hold what was going to be
coming out when they finally hit that
giant oil and gas deposit
down there at 20 000 feet under the
ground or whatever it was super deep
well that was deeper than that
so you you watched that movie with kirk
russell and the rest of it and
you know marky mark was an event horizon
the one where they they find
i'm sorry then horizons where they go
yeah event horizon is a spaceship yeah
that's
what i'm sorry i'm trying to remember
oil in the event horizon i'm like wait a
minute lawrence fishburne right here's
why i think they go to hell
here's my here's my brain deep water
water
pull up event horizon because that's a
great [ __ ] movie i love that movie
it's like they going downhill
they go into a new dimension also about
people but see how my brain got that
wrong but it's not on purpose no it's
okay event that's the [ __ ]
he pulls his eyeballs out he tells
everybody
yeah remember that yeah that's a great
[ __ ] movie pure evil
but listen i'm not trying to rant here
what i'm telling you joe is it's the
same thing with nuclear power plants
why would the executives at bp order
their engineers to do something that was
going to blow up they just said you
engineers are full of crap
we're going to make them might just be
arrogant engineers on adderall and they
made a big mistake
i don't know yeah that's what it could
be could be
that's what happened that is what
happened
well well those guys are probably
tweaked out right those those
executives what i'm saying it wasn't
engineers it was the executives
yeah but executives that's what i'm
saying why do you think they were like
keep pouring water in it keep pouring
water in it
because they were insane right i mean
that's what i'm saying about these
people the engineers
are at the mercy of these executives who
don't have the degrees the engineers
have
and they made a crucial error and they
forced the engineers to do something
that was ultimate and so i was agreeing
with you about we should listen to
scientists and engineers
i was just going back to your point that
yeah we don't know about the warming we
don't know what it's doing
the models they all use on warming
factor out the sun
right and you can't factor out the
southern equation i've had other
scientists that factor the sun in
and then they think despite all we're
doing
that within the next 200 years we're
going to it's very serious deep ice age
i think alex's point is that in all of
these things there are legitimate things
that you know kovid has
there there are real things people
getting sick global warming you know to
an extent
i'm sure is is happening of course it's
happening but then there are also
nefarious characters that want to use
that to take away your freedom there are
people that don't want you
owning a car there's all these legacy
systems whitney webb is a journalist who
came on my show
said a lot of people didn't want to
reopen the economy until they remade the
economy
and got rid of all these legacy systems
like and this is a dock
with eric schmidt it was the head of
google you could look it up and they
were saying you know
they were considering these legacy
systems like cash private ownership of
cars
you know things like that like getting
rid of all of these
things that are are distinctly american
ways of life and just saying that like
we don't want you to own a car this is
the most important thing that's been
said here today
one step at a time though why would they
want to get rid of
private ownership of cars because they
want control of people and if you allow
them to drive their own cars and use
cash
and run their own businesses and live in
their own home but let's start with cars
vertical integration let's start with
cars don't you think that
maybe the concern is they're looking at
the future of autonomous vehicles which
would drastically lower the mortality
rate on highways
and they're saying are they concerned
are the people that run this country joe
concerned with the mortality rate i mean
they're bombing other countries they're
doing this
they want centralized control hold
please we're steve wozniak the former
the founder of the apple stop says the
best ai is not as good as an answer
right this thought yeah but hold this
thought the mortality highways listen
you can't think if people are in the
woods with hoods up but the people with
at google that are working on autonomous
vehicles yeah
they're not the same people that are
trying to control governments all out
but
it's controlled by those guys all of
those people at google want to usher in
uh you know a brave new world they want
to remake uh the world in in
the way you're saying all these people
some of them are just writing software
to make a better picture
a lot of them that are not john joe i
really feel like i'm the [ __ ] voice
of reason
your nose
yeah you're very combative joe these are
utopians they want to create a
paradise on earth joe i brought you
through control i brought you the
documents joe
we have the i'm sucking on this cigar
like it's a jelly doughnut i'm hoping i
can get to the weed on the inside
i'm like i'm licking the outside what do
you got there a piece of paper
what does it say what does it say what
does it say i think it's confirmable
to the end of humanity what is this see
okay but it's a person who wrote this
it's adam kerr she's probably got a
pistol in his mouth right now
that's the wall street journal cover
story i really mean that adam i
apologize
that's the wall street journal cover
story may i please tell you what i came
here for
you came here for a reason yes hold on
here it is
covid19 has spotlighted the promise and
peril of transhumanism
the idea of using technology to overcome
sickness aging and death
okay but what is he saying i used to
fall asleep every night listening to
alex talk about this so i want to let
alex talk about this
until they took him off youtube okay but
make this the way i feel sleep every
night not only did they do that but do
you know they they [ __ ]
took a young turks podcast
podcast let's talk about that in a
minute can i please can we get some
weight in the aggressive
yeah we can get some we got something
outside no you need it no i can't i'll
blow it at you like
you get a cat high does that not cheated
if i blow it your face
i can't do it i'll blow it in your face
i can't do it
i'm getting kind of hot from the cigar
well you listen i need to talk to you
i'm a little lightheaded all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna go get some apple juice
and i'm gonna pray to jesus we got
something here listen listen i need to
talk to you they're still go go grab
yourself
go grab some bottles and some ice cream
get them some apple juice for the
transhumanism discussion please
listen you wonder why i'm so crazy no
because i discovered this stuff
uh right out of mainline documents and
i've known it for 26 years 27 years well
here's another thing let me tell you
something
i like we we all know that you've [ __ ]
some things up
right and the your biggest [ __ ] up is
sandy hook but you've gotten
so many things right this is why i keep
talking to you about these things and
why i defend you
and why i think that it's [ __ ]
dangerous
to censor you and to say oh this guy we
need to get him de-platform to get all
these things
you're revealing some things that have
been proven on the show
so far to be true that make people very
uncomfortable well the first thing i was
gonna do was thank you for having me on
and have the courage but i was gonna say
the [ __ ] bohemian grove thing the
bohemian grove thing that was amazing
that was the first time i really got
into what he was doing and that was like
amazing i mean when you watch that
movie watch that you know it's it's
paradigm shift i've had people
trying to minimize that i've had people
just they all do i go listen to me i'm
not a billionaire well i'll give you the
real take on it because i've been there
and i think it's just a gateway to
things but let's get into what we grow
in a moment
i really want to give you i i want to
give you the big enchilada
the big enchilada okay yeah just mole
sauce
yes sir just like i love molay sauce i
do too just like i'm saying the
engineers and
meanwhile a lot of them have good points
i'm not saying they're wrong about all
this stuff
i'm simply telling you i've read what
the globalists have to say in their own
establishment communication okay and
i have it right here in my notes to talk
to you about the post-human era
and the system that they are setting up
where in all of their main publications
they say humans are flawed humans are
bad
they are but they are flawed right but
then these corporations are saying
they're going to take us out of our
bodies and make a silicon
and that's what elon musk talks about be
where are those that worship ai gods
well he's actually talking about
neuralink which is something where
they're going to be able to interface
with your brain and increase the
bandwidth in which you access
information but go ahead
well that's it and that's it seems
inevitable doesn't it no it's not
inevitable
already driverless cars don't know a
wreck up ahead or what to do they have
more accidents
steve wozniak as i was saying earlier
the founder of co-founder of apple says
the best ai isn't a million percent you
know close
to how good an aunt's brain is stop stop
stop stop stop
when they first developed cars they said
well how are you going to take them
there's no roads sure ai
built roads here's the do you understand
that the ai that's powering these cars
now
is not you understand the people running
the ar predatory anti-humans that say
they want to get rid of this is not a
predatory anti
no i didn't say he was but i understand
he's working on autonomous vehicles he
said beware
those that speak of ai gods yes
okay a lot of people are worried that
look elon is more
concerned don't give me one of those you
keep that [ __ ] away from me no no no no
no he doesn't drink good thank you
he's sober broken all this extra i'm
sitting next to alex jones i'm as high
election night okay but listen listen
election night we're gonna get lit
but these guys who are making this
in hollywood this is fake this is only
uh corn syrup coloring
do you think this is a good idea though
this idea that we should be expanding
our minds in this way and putting our
chips on
don't think it's good or bad i think it
is the nature of human innovation
i think we take things we improve upon
them we
we do that with everything at one point
they had morse code right yes they went
from morse code to you being able to
send me
uh a facetime video understood well
these things happened
we're not against technology humans
we're not against technology okay
so you're not against technology but
what i'm saying is if you
follow technological innovation it
becomes
better and better and more and more
invasive we need to design it where it
doesn't make us obsolete humans take
control their environment
we build our environment the globalists
have decided to have a post-human future
where humans are no longer relevant this
is where you lose i can show you they're
damn close
but i'm he's getting me because i just
gave you an article i just gave you an
article
because i think he's right i think the
only reason we're still around is
because they haven't figured out how to
get robots good enough
to get rid of all of it if they had the
right robots there would be no walmart
they should get rid of everybody
you you don't think that if they were
the right robots
right they're making us obsolete they're
making us awesome
get rid of the world danger danger
cooler
i like to go to walmart is that okay not
but once you have a robot you won't want
to go to walmart
why because it's it's it's dirty it's
filthy everyone's got covered i listened
to you
that's why they're doing the coma that
is the poster you're not essential under
covet
they listen they want a sense they want
to train you okay listen
look how calculators were great no one
knows how to do math now look how phones
are great no one knows their numbers
anymore
all the statistics show that the science
of technology is making us dumb
and that's why they wrote the big
article the co-owner of sun microsystems
in 2000 bill joy wrote why the future
doesn't need us
and he explains he went to a top
billionaire tech conference and they
made the decision to not let humans
sit around and play video games in the
future that they were just going to
slowly phase us out and kill everybody
stop they're not trying to kill okay
pull up why the future doesn't need us
but why why wouldn't they
can we reverse engineer the question
because we're called useless eaters
i don't think they're trying to kill
people i think they're trying to improve
what a person is
what i think we're doing oh by chopping
our son's balls off
okay you're going to go down another
rabbit hole you son of a [ __ ] by
increasing
our ability to access information and by
becoming a
sort of a symbiotic creature aligned
with technology and once we're in line
with the ai can censor everything we do
you think big tech
the minute big tech got control they
began censoring and it's the groups
behind that are very predatory joe
i do agree with you there there's no
firewall
here's the problem the first amendment
currently does not apply to big tech
right i believe it should and
i believe that what's happening now with
whether it's twitter
or facebook or youtube these platforms
are so big i think the argument can be
made
that they are utilities and that they
should be regulated like youtube
it should be a human we did not i agree
we did not to have access to these
things
we did not talk about what we're going
to cover pretty much
we're going to talk about a lot of
things let's bring this this is what i
wrote last night okay you're ready
the silicon called i want you to take it
down enough the silicon cult
okay go ahead it's another article no i
wrote this oh you wrote it these are
talking points the silicon cult
defining the enemy the war on carbon
announce up front that i am not
really a liberal or conservative i want
a pro-human future please listen to me
and hear me out
let's stop right there because you get
called
a neo-conservative you get called
alt-right
you get called a far-right person when i
first
met you you were protesting against
george w
bush and you were saying that what he
was doing
and what he was trying to usher in what
was essentially going to be the downfall
of western
civilization even before he was elected
yes i remember that
so when people say alex jones is far
right guy i'm like
he's complicated he's he's really
against corruption
more than he's against any particular
party you just
found that the right was less apt to
censor you
and more apt to listen to your ideas
exactly and i know we're all
not stoned today and so we're being like
a little aggressive but here's the old
election night if i'm gracious enough to
be here or you're gracious enough i'll
be here
we'll we'll get hammered but listen
let's get into bohemian grove let's get
into the technology let's get into who
runs things let's get into the mindset
whatever points you want and i'll try to
just
go through it this is yeah this is
because you're saying they want
mortality on their own look at this thin
young handsome boyish baby-faced alex
jones
that's 2004. but yeah i mean i know you
in like 9.98
well in 98. i met you in 98 but i just
got to know you
this was when you were 98 was when you
were protesting and this is my cliff you
guys are welcome to play this it's
really good
yeah i'll sign a sign of form what is
what is going on in this game he's
interviewing a lizard
let's let's no this is this is the one
that's been a lot of different
newspapers
and that's the bohemian grove you want
to start it over it's david let me tell
you what i'm saying
we set it up okay right where he goes
david gergen i'm outside uh
what's the main thing in new york where
everybody plays by the way this is when
bill hicks was alive so i can confirm
that you are not building madison square
garden madison square
garden and here comes david gergen the
karl rove of like four or five
administrations
and i knew that he was part of the
actual ritual at bohemian grove so i
bring it up to him and he blows up at me
here it is okay
he's like eight feet about the tall
there yeah is our camera are you yeah
right there just about yeah but i
just want to get your permission first
here okay okay just it's local i can
i've i've got
no i understand we're talking to david
gergen
and he has advised several presidents
and of course has
written quite a few uh books and uh is a
i would call you a political pundit or
researcher
commentary it over the hill whatever one
last question
i read a washington times article many
years ago
where you had a comment about the
organization and then now it's been in
the wall street journal it's been a lot
of different newspapers
and that's the bohemian grove and back
in what was in 1996 when you joined
as a clinton advisor they were the
republicans were criticizing you oh what
about bohemian grove and then
you counted them and then you countered
them by saying hey i don't run around in
the woods naked what does that mean
here is the before mentioned washington
times article where he said i didn't run
around naked like they do
i don't i don't know what i don't know
what quote you're referring to i'm not
aware of any quote like that
uh listen uh i i am um
a happy member of the bohemian grove i
like the the folks who come there
and uh it's really inappropriate for me
to talk about a uh
the group beyond that thank you have you
been there for the ceremony with uh
the cremation of care uh frankly that's
uh that i don't think that's something i
need to talk to you about
now what we're watching for people that
are just listening is a bunch of people
wearing robes
that are burning an effigy in front of a
giant statue of molech the owl god and
it's the evidence of a child
well i don't know what it's that it's
what it is i think it's the effigy of a
child it looks like i believe it is a
grown woman
it's real mad right here and yeah okay
watch this
uh frankly that's uh that i don't know
five seconds we missed it
i said you take part in the ritual back
it up five seconds i'm alex jones that's
some information to care
uh frankly that's uh that i don't think
that's something i need to talk to you
about
really that's right well i'm alex jones
and i snuck in there in 2000. i'm the
guy that blew it wide open
and got the video it's been on national
tv well i disrespect you for that
you do i do but there's a lot of big
public officials going in there
you don't we deserve to know you too i
don't know anything about you and i
don't know about your film
but if you go in there with an
understanding you violated that
understanding by releasing that film and
i don't respect you for that
really you have a public appointment i'm
sorry you took an understanding when you
went in there that you would not
do that film and you did you haven't
understand when you went in there no did
you crash it
yes yeah and it has no trespassing signs
there too doesn't it no they put them
after oh i'm sorry i'm sorry sir i've
been there before i know what i want the
circumstances are
and i'm sorry you violated the
understandings but it was not that was
not a gentleman or anything today what
about the ritual is the ritual genuinely
that's all the people these [ __ ]
heads of state and billionaires that's
the other thing they run the world these
people i don't owe you this comment i
know
you you have you this is what's called
ambush journalism and i disrespect you
for that as well so thank you
goodbye that's not even your damn
business
oh all right listen oh
it's getting cocky you go around and and
make understandings with people and
violate them
you you should ambush people on the
streets when that that's inappropriate
form of journalism if you wish to
practice that that's fine but don't ask
others to respect you for it
if you want to you you can do you're
free american like anything you want if
you want to be uncivil
and rude and ungently that's up to you
but don't expect the rest of us to say
oh well you're mr gergen i'm sorry
nobody sets policy in there
we try to be a gentleman and obviously
you don't belong there weaving spiders
coming out here
yeah that is a three-parter
anyways that's a three point listen you
could ignore that if it was like a bunch
of poor people in the woods doing that
these guys even then i'd be worried even
then it would be weird these guys are
that are the top
of like every industry in america it's
at least
curious who goes in there well people
are like i mean clint eastwood's
gone he's not really a member look look
is it fun look it's 2 700 acres
it was set up by mark twain and it was a
liberal deal for like hookers and gateds
and just everything else just a big huge
would you say gateds what gateage gay oh
gay dudes i was like no i'm saying if
you go back to like the 1870s
when mark twain set up it was
classically liberal it was partying it
was their own 27 acres it was saloons
they brought in female hookers there was
gay guys in there everything
it was just it was bohemian groves well
they called that the people did whatever
they wanted it was it was so it was open
and they had like poetry and they had
plays and all the rest of it then
uh by the time howard taft became
president the republicans basically
bought it
so the reason is it's important is the
republicans go there
to like they ship in all these private
hookers all these jets land nearby
but they also have a lot of gay sex
which they use them to basically
compromise people
into the cult and so there's a lot of
gay sex how do you know this
uh it came out in news articles no one
ever got footage of it i was in there
for one day i snuck in and people i
looked good back then they hit on me a
lot
i had like you know people i recognized
from tv walking right let's go right now
i mean it's a big gay hookup deal for
republicans i'm just telling you what it
is
and and then and then they've got this
this ritual that's only the feeder group
so i'm sitting there during the ritual
and i'm like hey this is pretty cool but
you go shut up i'll kill you
and they're all taking it very seriously
and i'm not saying it's a gay thing i'm
saying something that goes on
you were saying it was cool and people
were getting angry that you were saying
no i mean i was just quietly going oh
this is really interesting they're like
shut up this is a very important ritual
and they were taking it very serious
this hearse comes in
with the body of a child it is an effigy
they're not killing it and
it's just a bundle of sticks right yeah
well it looks like a kid no well later
others infiltrated later that worked
there and got his photos of it it's an
image of a kid
it's a little kid because mulligan in in
biblical is who they they sacrifice the
canon
it's a bull but they do it as an album
but that's from the bible is you would
sacrifice a child to give not your
children to the fires of mullet
right and and so i've given it to
experts in religious history it's not
even you know from christian perspective
it's a faustian deal mixed with
babylonian and religious
stuff from tyre yeah it's quirky look at
that look at that owl god and look at
the fire
underneath the owl god and there's
ronald reagan i mean if you saw that if
you were in the woods and you just saw
that you would be
terrified and richard nixon says
richard nixon on the richard nixon tapes
says it's a gay orgy
richard nixon said that you can pull up
richard nixon talks about yeah richard
nixon said something about it where
he the most goddamn [ __ ] thing you ever
seen i think it's i think it's just
allowing well nothing against that's
what it's saying
i think it's guys that aren't gay that
are that are that engaging gay acts
in the woods and then they have
something on each other similar to
epstein's island
that's right it's that's what it's a
rich it's a it's a it's like a
fraternity doing that you're gonna screw
up something
is that poison hold on a second what is
this here and they don't allow women
no it says uh founded in 1872 by a group
of male 1 that's the context
that youtube has let me talk about
bohemian grove this is the title of the
video
i'm told you found 18 richard nixon
bohemian grove most
[ __ ] goddamn thing he could ever
imagine yeah
yes play it a hundred percent play it i
want to hear some nixon tapes yeah
let me hear this
northern california you know what's
happening in san francisco
but it isn't this is just not an iraqi
part of town
but the upper class of the san francisco
is that way the elohim grower that i am
in
one time at the time the others have
come there
but it is the most vague goddamn that
you will ever imagine
the san francisco crowd goes in there
it's just terrible okay
so weird the owl and the uh it's
interesting and it
i don't know how seriously they take it
i mean that's the real question right
well yeah
i mean the whole gate thing's a side
issue right the point is is that
i've talked to people that i mean
according to ted gunderson the first
time i've ever heard about this was from
this former high-level fbi agent who's
gonna be the fbi director but he
wouldn't go along with corruption so he
wasn't it's on record gunners and almost
being the fbi director and he blew up
like the things like the franklin
scandal and he's been
the finders and the financial level
which was huge yeah which where the cia
was caught
trafficking you know the finders is a
cult that was called trafficking
children
and the cia squashed the florida uh
and then gundersen got it rated in in dc
and found a whole cia facility
with the snuff films every relax machine
and so he told me about all this and i
thought he was crazy
even though he was ted gunderson you
told us about it and we actually
pulled up one of those stories and i was
correct yes you're correct yes
yeah thank you so ted gunner says the
reason i know about this and he said
he said that they get people interested
with that ritual most there's like 2 000
members they bring about a thousand
guests not everybody can bring a guest
unlike the head of each camp can bring a
guest most of them are nice clint
eastwood goes there you know
danny glover goes there but it's an
all-male deal who's the other one danny
glover oh danny glover i'm just
mentioning it who's
the weapon danny that's all in there how
the [ __ ] is he in there
they probably like him from there he's
just a fun guy i saw him when i was
there
i saw that interesting i'm starting to
believe this is not i'm sorry to believe
we can get in i'm starting to believe
it's not bad
joe rogan they'd have him in immediately
i mean not now do a podcast
in front of the owl but i just want to
say that
overall what started out as a it's a
truly artsy liberal thing that i think
is good
i think guys deserve to go off the woods
like we've done since
humans were humans and party and do
whatever
right and so and so it's but the thing
is then the weird skull here's what
happened
about 1900 skull and bones that was at
uh yale
in new haven connecticut that was a
german death cult it took over bohemian
grove and that's when they set up that
as the central deal so it's this big
inviting fun party
what happens is skull and bones because
that's one of the other rumors about
skull and bones they
compromise you i know they compromised
you so that you're always a part of this
organization before he died i did
multiple interviews with anthony sutton
the top
congressional advisor to senator frank
church
and we only know about sutton because
charlotte israeli whose father was
high-level skill and bones
gave him all of their internal manuals
and she's been a frequent guest she's
retired now
america's secret establishment an
introduction to the order of skull and
bones
yes okay and so this is this is a
russell trust uh true illuminati
illuminati set up
1776 to counter our revolution by adam
visable it funds the jacobins
it funds the french revolution it's it's
the opposite of a true egalitarian open
liberal revolution
it's the leftist always say they're the
liberal liberal and leftists are two
different deals
leftist is left hand past satanism
liberalism is egalitarian open society
true liberalism
and so the left-hand path uh set this up
and then they wanted they sent all this
opium money they had over in 1831
to yale to set up a german secret
society of the illuminati
which then has become one of the
dominant secret societies and in there
they do actual satanic rituals
they get in coffins uh they they do
simulated human sacrifices
they have gay sex as part of the ritual
they they bathe in
uh huge facilities of feces uh this was
this was a made by robert de niro made a
movie
skull and bones are doing that stuff now
absolutely i know somebody broke into it
but wow who's the
how can this be proven well matt damon
made a movie
called the good shepherd i think yes and
and in that it's robert de niro directed
it
okay and that's super accurate where
it's got the sword and the devil and
they're in they're in these big vats of
calming they did leak a facebook uh
photo album of a bunch of skull and
bones kids hand on a deer island that
kind of looked like losers
i know they're not nobody i know they're
not but they kind of look like lose i
mean it was kind of like embarrassing
billionaires look like losers yeah they
look like emaciate you were like these
are the
these are the illuminati it was kind of
like no i totally agree with you yeah
remember abc news because they wanted to
get bush in trouble right before the
2004 election
another frat was able to because they're
all doing this crap shoot video down
into it where they're going devil equals
death satan and they had girls they
finally brought into the membership
it was all boys before yeah sacrificing
so of course it's idiotic
it's training wheels for what they do
but inside they go grave rob they've got
geronimo skull
yeah the george h.w bush stole
supposedly stole geronimo skull yeah you
got to do things like i don't know if
that but that's a root that's a
legend rumor thing yeah it's probably
been broken into yeah one time the
police went in there but the point is
is that skull and bones order 322
is the illuminati germanic death cult
that now set up chapters all of the u.s
and it took over bohemian grove
around 1900 and so that's why bohemian
grove is still this
artisan you know deal of elitist artist
but then it got co-opted by the
republican party in skull boats
and helmet schmidt german chancellor
wrote men in power as a political
retrospective
we retired in the late 80s saying i love
our illuminati rituals
that we have in germany in our own
sacred groves but i think they've taken
to a new level with skull and bones
at bohemian grove and i really enjoy the
time we have there
so these are just these elite
institutions where
and skullenbones i think they seek to
like create uh
close friends amongst people that may
not know each other create loyalty
amongst this group of people that's why
they got to tell them all the things
that yeah you got to tell them all the
sexual history all that stuff
they want these people to be loyal to
each other so when they they're not
loyal to the laws of america they're
loyal to this this oath that they take
with each other and exactly and it's
like a team america
look at this descendant sue's skull and
bones over geronimo's bones
documents show george h bush george w
bush's grandfather rob
geronimo's grave members members of the
secret society allegedly steal
valuable things and put them in tomb
great
grandson says geronimo should be burned
buried
in accordance with tradition federal law
protects native americans rights to
their family member's remains
and let's expand on that what he just
said because this guy's done he's
studying
it's like thank you it's like a team
america when the head guy goes
she's the only person who's ever said
i've said no no nobody says you go suck
my [ __ ] gary it's not about sex
in skull and bones in bohemian grove
what he said is most these guys are not
gay
it's an act of dominance like oh you're
a senator you want to be president bend
over and like a former president screws
you in the ass
and that's what they do i mean the
ritual is i'm in charge bend over
well isn't that a thing with
fraternities anyway like hazing the
jizz on a cracker exactly so it's the
next deal yeah but most people are
fraternity i mean these are the
top kids these are kids that they think
are going to occupy leadership positions
in the world and often do and often do
so even let me give you an example even
john ronson saw the photo with me when
we stuck in bohemian grove yeah
and and they had it hanging and people
say why don't you get a video i have a
camera hidden right here
it's henry kissinger bent over in a
woman's dress sticking his fingers in
his ass
bill clinton in a blue dress with jeff
in jeffrey epstein's house yeah but
that's just an artist's rendition do you
know that that was just an artist made
that yeah but maybe this was an artist
tradition
we're in a clubhouse yeah bronson wrote
about this oh so
it's a photo or a painting no it was a
it looked like a photo but let's just
say it's a painting i don't know it
wasn't i mean
it's ancient memory 20 years ago okay 20
plus you know but i mean bronson's like
look at that i'm like oh is that
kissinger yeah it's kissinger
it's all about being improper and then
they all go get
caught to compromise each other to be in
the club it's a hazing thing so that
they can trust each other because
they're all doing shady [ __ ] yeah yes
even if it's an artist's rendition why
does jeffrey epstein have it in his
townhouse a picture of the president in
a blue dress well because the president
flew in his [ __ ] well that's what i
mean that's what i mean he was busy
and by the way maxwell has now come out
in court it's getting no attention
confirming
okay clinton did fly to that island that
broke four days ago it's gotten zero
yeah no they're not paying they're not
paying attention we haven't heard
anything other than those court
documents
listen i told you listen guys it's not
like i'm even that special
my mom's brother was a famous helicopter
pilot in vietnam
running black ops into laos and cambodia
and stuff and then he
i i shouldn't tell these stories but no
one's ever heard this stuff
but you know i remember growing up and
telling me this stuff and it was it was
true
like they were i'm like i'm not going to
do it please
i just can't do it what's the danger you
said so much uh
well no i mean let's just say he took
the fall for something that was going on
he didn't get in trouble for it he got
promoted
and he was involved in iran contra and
that's how people get promoted they fail
upward by
taking a lot of times to blame for
something or this is
that's like so i grew up i i mean i grew
up not just him but other family you
know that was it was like something
special
you know about those navy seal guys you
got a security done a bunch of crazy
stuff that's what our military does it's
not what you hear on the news
right and and and it's just completely
out of control stuff
right and i mean my uncle told me he
said he said yeah i know i got out
of working for these groups and
everything uh as you know an army
officer that was sheep dip he wasn't
there we wouldn't yeah he wasn't wearing
an army uniform
yeah right hot we were talking high
level like you're talking running the
real stuff like right
here well he was in charge he liked the
command base in guatemala city right
because he was like a top morse code guy
yeah of course he had satellites there
but nobody could read this morris code
coded so he was sending stuff to the
white house moore's coat like
he was like when he was a kid he was a
champion morse coder so he wasn't just
in command he was like running all the
stuff
and uh he just said i had to do it
because he said it was
kids being smuggled out of orphanages by
the cia for sex ops in dc
jesus christ right he told me that he
told me that when he was dying of
pneumonia
jesus [ __ ] yeah now what is it with
kids why is the way to compromise people
it's the it's the energy too
yeah i mean if somebody will hurt kids
and he wouldn't if somebody will hurt
kids
like what else they'll do anything but
that's what everyone's so terrified of
today right that there are
some sex trafficking and sex cultures
and there's ten times over ten times i
love people but that's like
they are there but that's a fact right
but if you want to get on [ __ ] gets wild
and it's sloppy and messy and you've
talked about that too it gets sloppy and
messy and they're not right about
everything
but the idea there are human traffic the
the entire
is just people on the internet they're
like playing games larping
acting like they're taking credit for
something and a lot of them are good
people it's just that
you can give them like bona fide like
look they just busted a giant child
trafficking ring associated press
they don't want that they want no
there's underground bases and there's
dinosaurs they're sailing wants the real
[ __ ]
they don't want to want so is it that
they're just into things that are
just huge more ridiculous than reality
like what is
yeah because it's escapism and hillary's
in prison secretly
oh right i think they just learned about
the world over the last year and it
melted their mind like you've been
looking at
when you were wrong with joe a few
months ago you crystallize it perfectly
yeah they've been asleep
now they've woken up and now they think
everything's a cartoon version well say
like you said yeah well it was just like
again it's like if you didn't know
anything about the franklin scandal you
didn't know about epstein or you hadn't
read these books you didn't know the
stories your uncle told you and then
eventually you just found out there was
an
island where all these politicians were
going to and having sex with kids and
they were getting compromised
your mind would melt and then you would
get paranoid and then you would start
thinking that everybody's a pedophile
and that there's
tunnels underground when the reality is
it is bad
but sometimes you have to take a step
back and take a breath and realize that
like
there are good people and not everybody
is
evil but there is a lot of evil out
there but you got to take a step back
and try to realize like what is what
well there's one picture of clinton
getting massaged by this woman
and they were using it as uh sort of
evidence but the woman's clearly a woman
she's in her 20s and they were saying
she'd been working for him since she was
like 15.
let's never use clinton as the example
of the q and on people being wrong
that's not even what i'm saying it's
never there it is that's a grown woman
she's a grown-up yeah so listen let's be
clear the media did a limited hangout
they went with these whistleblowers
instead of all the other people
and and the fact that the the witnesses
reported at epstein island
in the caribbean little st george on the
other island too
that boats would pull up the middle of
the night to the shacks
with with little brown kids and those
are the ones that get disappeared but
who who reported this
it's in it's in the uh it's in major
documentaries it's in netflix
documentaries it's in all the witnesses
we talked to
and they said my witnesses my people i
talked to over 10 years ago said
you remember me telling you about it
they've got an island the caribbean
they've got an island in the
mediterranean
they've got ranches in the southwest and
that they
well he had a ranch in new mexico right
yeah that came out later i wasn't told
exactly where i mean the idea that these
kids would disappear potentially
isn't crazy no it's not crazy not crazy
at all here's an example
i was told by a high-level source that
major hollywood producers by name
ran a cult where they branded women next
to their vagina the nixium thing
but but i put it out two years before it
broke so i was told this by high level
source i remember you talking to me
about it
and and then they had a they even had
articles going in huffington post jones
claims
harvey weinstein's connected to groups
that you know do all this
and i was just going off what people
told me
and i said i didn't even say weinstein
that's what's crazy is
they were already trying to cover it in
case i said that they're like oh
weinstein's not involved the branding
women well it never even came out he was
it was the other guy
right so it's just but what you said did
turn out to be true
yeah as fantastic as it sounded as
outrageous
as ridiculous it turned out to be true
now
it's in the news first time i ever heard
of ted gunderson let me pull him out ted
gunderson
it's on wikipedia up to be fbi director
he was the head of la imagine what he
learned there he's telling me he goes
man i've been the fbi 20 years i got to
be the head of l.a he was like it's
devil worshiping everywhere
blew me away you know pedophilia you
name it um
he knew about the manson thing really
being a satanic ritual and there's a
senator from nebraska named john decamp
who was friends with who he was friends
with and john decamp was a guy who
he blew the whole thing wide open like
he was cia he blew the whole thing wide
open
well that was um that was his mentor so
de camp's mentor
was um a guy who was a high-level cia
guy who jamie can pull that up he was
in a phoenix operation and he was killed
and i feel like
in the in the in the uh in the canoe and
you know the dinner was still on the
table he was killed in a canoe yeah this
was a high-level cia guy john decamp was
a nebraska senator who broke open
this human trafficking operation this by
the way i'm having a hold on hold on
yeah no there's a pedophile cult it was
trafficking kids across america
and it was centered out of the omaha
federal uh omaha
federal credit union was being run by a
guy named larry king was this rising
star in the republican party he's
probably still alive
he has pictures of maureen reagan all
that stuff these kids
were being trafficked to dc to la to new
york wherever
de camp stumbled upon this stumbled upon
the occult weird
ritual [ __ ] going on too in addition to
the pedophilia and all that
and then he went to this guy his mentor
who he knew from from vietnam from the
military who was a cia guy whose name is
escaping me
william colby william colby you went to
liam called me and william colby
basically said to the camp listen
you're going up force you're going up
against forces that are way too powerful
you don't even know what you're you're
knocking on here and then william colby
i think changed his mind and said [ __ ]
it you know what
we should stop doing like let's if we're
gonna fight this let's fight it
and then a little while later william
colby who was in great healthcare
yeah has an accident in his canoe is
found dead
um in a river right by his house with
his dinner still on the table so it's
like nobody nobody gets up in the middle
of the dinner to go canoeing
so this has been a common theme forever
whereas if you go against these
these people you find you're dead he was
76 when he drowned though
yeah but in a canoe while his dinner was
still sometimes people have heart
attacks when they're 76. i understand i
understand i understand that okay we're
connecting dots here that maybe we don't
need to
disclos okay uh william colby director
of central intelligence chose to
disclose some of the nation's darkest
secrets to save the spy service he loved
drowned on april 27th at a tributary
who was a private investigator hired to
get to the bottom of the it's like barry
steele man they're getting rid of the
people they just get rid of them
all right so so listen we've done
bohemian grove we've done
let me tell you senator de camp was on
record running
major level operation phoenix which was
a high-level cia torture operation
and an execution operation so uh
apocalypse now is kind of based on some
of the things they did
but he's on record highly decorated at
that i don't want to go too far away
from the epstein thing because i still
have a whole lot more
let's go back to epstein okay the island
itself like first of all epstein had
this
crazy place in new york city seven-story
palace that
the guy who owned victoria's secrets he
gave it to him
yeah because of probably blackmail right
and then there was other billionaires
who it turned out had and this is like
had been glossed over including bill
gates
bill gates stays there and tried to deny
it but bill gates denies
uh staying with uh epstein but confirmed
he stayed there and in his paris home
okay and uh this was also he met with
him
post his first arrest correct yes
because he was arrested yeah a lot of
people did chelsea handler i did it with
him i believe after the arrest too i
mean a lot of people looked past that
apparently
british royal okay bill gates met with
jeffrey epstein many times despite his
past
and they're gonna say jamie's really
fast he's the best he's the best
um so
let's let's go back to this american
where are you absolutely getting
a huge interest in tech we love tech yes
yes
and he wanted to he he brought
scientists and and big tech people over
his house in new york city here's the
deal
they were doing i said this over 10
years ago
that they were involved in secret
breeding programs for cloning
okay before we get to that scientists
how were they getting these signs where
are they getting all the money first of
all
where's he getting the money get the
silent where's he getting the money to
to buy this giant or get he was we now
know that he was a nexus point from the
dirty sides
of the cia mi6 and mossad at least yeah
and so they were compromising people and
then as he would compromise people
most of them knew they were being
compromised they wanted to be
compromised to be let in
to then run operations and be given even
more money he was also the money manager
for a guy named les wexner who's a
billionaire who owns victoria's secret
the limited among other things
that's the guy he was gifting epstein a
property he gave him a seven
well that's where he got some of the
first money well eric weinstein who's a
legit yes
financial guy looked at him and said
this guy doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about
he said he's playing a role and then
scientists were like that too when they
went to his house to go
oh epstein's is is like playing a role
yes he has no
you know so whatever he's doing he's
working for somebody well let me tell
you they want to corrupt the scientific
elite to go along with their agenda on
climate change
to go along with their agenda on viruses
to go along with their agenda because
they know
scientists are respected so you want to
have them compromised so they should go
on whatever it is you want so whatever
it is you want so if you want to do
something and manipulate reality
to make your agenda
go through you compromise the scientists
and then these elite experts who you
have
on film having sex with 16 year olds
then you yeah so maybe man-made global
maybe man-made level warming is real and
really bad doesn't matter the solution
they have as a global tax you pay them
so it's a scam but as big as epstein was
he was small
compared to these other finders groups
and other organizations
that even came out in the news at the
time in the late 80s early 90s and then
the communist chinese
they're running the blackmail rings with
hunter biden and the democratic party
and
dianne feinstein and all these people at
levels
way way way above anything anybody else
has seen jesus christ
i always i always got a bad feeling from
dianne feinstein
i never had anything turned out her main
our main assistant was a chinese actual
agent
yeah maxwell powell pleads for release
says
jailed heiress sir starving and
humiliating clothes
and that's unfair for her and i think i
mean this is the leader's statement you
should give her
oh oh she i mean on record this woman
was involved with all these horrible
things and now
oh my god she said humiliating clothes
why do you think trump
said like when they asked her about it
well i wish her well he's always smart
ass like
because epstein was killed in prison so
he's like i wish her well because i want
to get data he's also like a rich guy he
knew her
right i mean well he later clarified it
i gave you what he said
do you think trump's cleaning everything
in in this extent i mean oh you want to
get the ml on trump well i
would like to because i know that yeah
i'll give you no no
here we go my only superpower is that i
really try to give you the accurate
thing doesn't mean i'm always right
about 95 of the time that's why earlier
went down that rabbit troll what i'm
saying listen trump doesn't like
lobbyists he fired him only trying to
make the best decisions for everybody in
a pragmatic free market
to not have one side of trade deals but
his blind side was by him not letting
lobbyists in
everyone around him became unofficial
lobbyist that became a 20-minute lab
rabbit i'm not bitching about okay but
let me tell you about trump
trump's dad was a super right-wing
pro-america dude
who was actually a huge founder of the
john birch society
he introduced him to uh the
head of the house un-american activities
group
that worked for nixon and eisenhower
that actually ran the red scare
some of it was good as it was bad roy
cohen and so his personal lawyer
for 25 years was roy cohen who
was like joe mccarthy's best friend
right joe mccarthy's chief of staff
chief of staff yeah i mean he ran it and
he ran it yeah he ran house and senate
he was
he was the big enchilada and so trump
was actually heavily influenced by his
father that was anti-communist
acted nice and liberal in new york but
like knew all this john bert society
like you know we're talking whole nine
yards but wasn't roy cohn also involved
in some blackmail stuff oh he was
huge okay all right absolutely and it
was the whole game obviously right
right right yeah christ you guys are
deep you're deep in this i know that
yeah i know this is all asleep listening
every night i would fall asleep i'd
listen to about a half hour and then i
would trail off him
and i would fall asleep and now i can't
do that anymore thank you youtube
you can infowars.com i know we're
halfway into this i should say
people ask where people come to say i
used to love you i'm sorry you're all
fair now
we have record traffic at infowars.com
and band.video
band.video we have videos i've had
videos this week with three million
views two million views a million views
yeah it's all there my producer ben
avery watches in forrest.com during
holidays
your family be having christmas so i'm
in a room watching influence so speaking
of censorship youtube
and facebook have now banned all the q
and on stuff right which is crazy
well this is what's crazy like what's
next you gonna ban
jfk conspiracy well if i make a joke
about q anon am i gonna get banned
that's the other problem
but it's like you said the the young
turks show well let's just first talk
about the yeah
what is the the show that what's the
jacobite because
uh tim dillon had put the uh the show
uh he he put i'm gonna i'm gonna send it
to you jamie so you could see what it is
uh i'm gonna send you the uh video that
tim uh
dillon or excuse me tim sent me i'm
gonna send it to you right now jamie
so let me explain this okay
the young turds are anti-free speech for
everybody including me and then she goes
but i'm not anti-free speech i just want
alex jones band
but then they have this new show called
the jacobins well let's talk about evil
the young turks were the group that ran
the armenian genocide
they ran the armenian genocide on record
kill over a million half christians
they named themselves the young turks
they go oh we don't know what that means
now they're called the jacobins the
jacobins
ran the french revolution right and were
the illuminati i told you about them
earlier yeah
so it's like every name they've got is
like the hitler youth basically
i mean you know the the young turks and
that is a
very unfortunate name well they also
people run around
with you know the people who watch a lot
of those shows walk around with
either the chickavera shirts or they're
unironically calling themselves maoists
these are like suburban white kids
walking around going on my mallet 100
smartphones
right yeah yeah that is a problem i
think they're trying to do good and i
think they think they are doing good i
really do
i think when they thought that hey uh
i'm not
uh anti-free speech but ban alex jones
right
they just don't understand what that
means there's a reason
why you can't just go around censoring
people
and again the answer to bad speech
is better speech right that has always
been the answer but here's the big
problem
once they silence you they can then make
up whatever they want because people all
the time here's what's worse
alex and this is you personally but the
problem is when they silence someone
with a censor someone
and then that person's not the that's
that's not the target anymore
they look for another target and they
invariably go left
they invariably exactly get on a power
trip
but hold on a second the left is not
left enough
so if you're a centrist they'll call you
all right yeah
because you need to be compliant
completely with the ideology if you're
not compliant
they they will they keep moving what's
acceptable
and what constitutes racism sexism
classism homophobia transphobia
it's a power grab but they keep changing
it and they move the line
or orwell talked about this in 1984 yeah
he was like
if you ban all the words if all you you
will you
literally you will be you will change
thoughts because you you can't have all
the i forget
orwell's words on uh on
producing language he said he said what
they want to reduce the language
where no one's even able to communicate
and that's the goal so we think of it as
a leftist thing that's out of control no
i paraphrased it and i [ __ ] it up but
the point is what they didn't see
they didn't use hindsight they didn't
they well they didn't it's called
sock well that what they did it's so
hard to talk with you
what they didn't do is they didn't look
joey they didn't
look to where this goes they didn't
understand they didn't extrapolate they
didn't say or maybe some of them
did and some of them wanted to go if you
start if you start censoring
there's a real pr and i know people are
saying no you should censor people that
say terrible things because they
influence our children and
you you can't but joe it's a power grab
they get off once they've got one scalp
they're going to scalp everybody
including themselves and that's the
motivation of the people that are doing
it
that's not what i'm concerned with what
i'm concerned with is the problem itself
because you keep finding a new target
you keep
finding a new a new person who's doing
something that's
that's what i'm saying they don't want
to give up they want more more more but
it's not that they're trying to grab
power it's just you're always trying
look you've you've started the game yeah
they're losers that want to control
reality because they're projecting their
own hatred for themselves on us you
don't think part of it is that they want
power to control the discussion
there's most certainly a part of that
yeah that's a part that's human nature
but joe you just said i'm hard to
deal with well because you talk over
people when they're talking you don't
let them get the full you've been
talking a lot
you get you don't let people get a full
thought out they're
in tim does it like when he's thought
what i was saying is he's talking and
you you jump in and the problem is i
know you have some things to say but
then you [ __ ] with the thing that's
coming out of the other person okay
explain to me how the sensors are loving
people that's what you're trying to do
not saying they love people i'm saying
they don't they they're not
looking at it correctly because the way
they're looking at it they think they're
doing a good thing and they're going to
usher for some
utopian uh world of communication where
people are only saying the things they
agree with
the problem with that is you don't find
out who's right unless you get everybody
talking
but still i agree the only way it's
worse than that you can't have an echo
chamber
it's dangerous echo chambers are
dangerous and in what tech has done
is created these left-wing ideological
echo chambers
i totally agree and they're also forcing
people into self-censorship
because if you don't comply with the
rules that they've set forth
then you get banned so you comply and
you you you find
you find people it is a cult ideal
ideologically like this listen it is a
cult
joe i think there's a lot of these
cultures what i'm trying to say to you
is you've
never been not smoking weed with me on
air
you need i know it's a bummer we should
have had you come in a week you're
donald trump is going to win you think
so but then the democrats are going to
contest it
and we're going to have the 79 days but
why are all the polls showing that joe
biden is in the lead do you think it's
all possible
like last time they said hillary was
gonna win yeah but these are the post
post uh election polls joe what i want
to do is talk to you right now
why are you talking like that he's like
a funny he's a conspiracy phone sex
operator
right now he's the only one here drunk
this is a real problem
tim dylan he's tim hills that's not how
tim dylan talks tim dillon's looking at
you right now do you
do you really think that trump is going
to win because he's close now he's going
to win big
interesting really but they're going to
think that but but they're going
listen i was not trying to interrupt you
earlier
well you this is how you talk it's okay
you you're you're there you're going
you've got to laugh
you've talked twice as much in our last
four-hour podcast i love it this is the
sober joe rogan
let's get back to this trump what were
we arguing about about political
correctness i don't know but you were
saying that we weren't arguing he was
saying that the senator's agreeing with
you the censors some of the sensors are
trying to do the right thing yes
and that you were saying listen it's
deeper than that and then that's where
we left off
it's all been scientifically set up
where they always say oh we're for
outliers now
and dog whistles it's all about
normalizing centralized control
big technos it's psychological
algorithms it's totally destructive
china that has people in muslims in
death camps
christians in death camps buddhists and
is trying to totally normalize
censorship here domestically
when the whole left is involved with
communist china through big tech it
doesn't say a word about them they have
no
moral high ground to stand on joe well
we have a real problem in this society
when when it comes to tech
first of all because all the people that
are on the moral high ground who are
buying iphones you know where those
things are being made
like we all we all know everybody knows
and i admit it i admit it
i admit it as well there's no iphones
that are being made in ohio with highly
skilled workers that are paid
an excellent wage and they have great
health care benefits
that's not what's happening i don't know
why but that's not what's happening sure
they've decided that it's better to make
them cheaper
or better to have a higher profit margin
and make them in
other countries or at least they decided
that initially and now they're stuck
let me ask you this who do you think is
going to win
in fact i will be very subdued now since
i'm back joe jorgensen
yeah i think joe jorgensen has a great
shot she's she's a shoe-in
and then kanye west i think joe jorge
said kenny west i think it's an it's a
nail but
it's it's neck and neck it drives me
crazy like it's neck and neck right
jennifer aniston
was she made a tweet that said drives me
crazy is you're hating me right now
i love you because you're not drinking
hold on a second
there was a [ __ ] hilarious um
response by kanye west she said uh
jennifer aniston put on twitter hey it's
not
funny to uh vote in for kanye don't do
it
and he goes friends wasn't funny either
hilarious he's right he's right
that's great frisbee's not funny but
it's you see the two of them together
friends was a funny show joe you were
great on friends i wasn't on friends
that's a joke who do you think you think
trump
i don't know if you were a friend's
character who would you mean
you might be matt leblanc right will you
be jennifer anderson
i don't think so
[Laughter]
who's matt leblanc his name is joe
jennifer's the most successful
i identify as jennifer he was dumb i'm
dumb perfect wouldn't you like to have a
dentist like jennifer aniston horrible
bosses
uh she was a dentist what did she do
molester uh patience whether you're
under okay
well you could be molested by worse
people well they're not kids i just
think it's funny that they
yeah someone who's an actor would say
that like this
this thing that they feel like they have
this influence they're gonna change the
way people vote
this 80 days of hell you speak of what
does that entail just so i can mentally
prepare myself 79 days
79 days of households 79 days without
broken what's going to happen 79 days of
us locked up in here with cases of
whiskey
and huge piles of marijuana yeah he's
lit
no no no you're a little lit buddy i
don't actually i could see that bottle
and it was a fresh bottle when you said
no
that's that's that's fake that's
hollywood that's not hollywood we're in
texas i gave up hollywood years ago
i haven't worked in hollywood let's talk
about this what were you just asking
i don't know 79 days of hell the
democrats could test the election
problem 79 to see this is not fair
79 days of hell
that's how many days there are after
november third to the inauguration
and john podesta in the new york times
they had a big war game
with the new york times sat in on a
democrat high-level war game with
hillary clinton and
joe biden and all of them and they said
we're going to contest we think we're
going to win
but if we lose we're still going to
contest and we're going to contest
and we're going to call for the u.n to
come in and occupy the u.s the u.n is
going to occupy the u.s and then and
then the new york times came out and
said we need the u.n
to intervene in the u.s election and now
the four horsemen
uh just called for that yesterday jesus
and so they are planning to have who's
the four horsemen
aoc and the rest of the crew oh jesus
christ
and so those i thought that's the tribe
anyways and so they're there and they're
planning to have western states
western states secede and they're saying
they're going to hold the election up
you already saw this they already denied
the last election they could take
portland yeah you take it all it takes a
lot of the
79 days of hell let me ask you this who
cares
you when did you decide to try to escape
california well i told you the looting
with the looting hand
you told me off-air yeah i had zero
faith
in their ability to uh maintain law and
order because
if you're gonna pay all that money in
taxes i feel like you should at least
feel like they're protecting things
and when they were just letting them
smash windows and cops were told
to stand down particularly in santa
monica there was like direct orders and
the sheriff was
you know being widely criticized for
this they were told to stand down while
these people were smashing and looting
things
um when when they were doing that i was
like well
you can't live in a place where that's
being tolerated because this is
this this this goes from stores
to you know they'll move to nightclubs
and move to restaurants they'll decide
it had nothing to do with george floyd
no it had nothing to do with him i agree
those restaurants those stores had
nothing to do with george floyd and now
like in minnesota minneapolis
the crime rate's like triple the police
won't even show up they're like people
like why are you even paying you yeah so
what do you think both of you
mr dylan what is the end game of this
i'm going to finish my
my answer okay so i'm not done yet it
was also that there was restrictions
that were put in place that didn't make
any sense to me
there's restrictions for restaurants
restrictions for comedy clubs restrict
restrictions for gyms like why can't you
just wear them
churches clothes but all but walmart's
open well why are churches closed but
why is it okay to protest
why is everybody okay why is everybody
letting people protest
right why aren't they saying listen i
understand your your
want and desire to protest but
understand that you're most likely
contributing to the spread of this virus
because that's a fact right even if you
support the protests
yeah the end game seems to be if you let
society get bad enough people will then
accept
all these more draconian security
measures and
and censorship across the board do you
think that's what's going on with
california like why do you think they've
kept california locked down this much
they want to kill the u.s economy
china's been open for six months they
admit it's it's leaked out that they're
doing this to kill the us economy
remember
it's leaked out how uh let's come out
democratic party
uh reports it's it's it's been stated
you heard democrats all over the news
say we wanted depression to make trump
look bad
who said this uh bill maher yeah but
bill maher is not a part of the
democratic party he's a comic i don't
know but i used it
but he jokes around about that like look
okay we'll crash the economy okay well
regardless when jews try to
or baptist in new york try to have an
event the police show up and arrest him
but then when antifa or blm was around
burn stuff down the mayor says it's
great
and the mayor said de blasio said this
is legitimate
antifa is legitimate your church isn't
your synagogue isn't so it's power it's
selective enforcement
it's martial law i have articles right
here because everything i brought today
i have the proof
abc news is reporting in blue cities in
texas
that they're going to come to your house
and demand a coveted test and if you
don't they're going to arrest you
well the federal and state courts they
can't do that where is that being said
el paso texas but i want to bring you
back to what you're saying about crash
the economy you use bill maher as an
example and i just don't think that's a
credible example because he's a comic
book well he said that
yeah but he's a comic and they always
play this
the comics have bigger coverage than
news people now that's what colbert and
all them poses
people alex you can't use him
as an example of someone who's a
politician
who is calling i think for the economy
strategically if i was a democrat
i wouldn't want things to open up again
until trump was out right agreed
i mean that's true
shut down china admits they're using the
virus to keep us shut down
i think he's a bio weapon we'll actually
give you an hour-long treatise i'll go
with 19 okay
we'll we'll get to that momentarily okay
i don't want to anger you though before
before we no i love being here i'll sit
here and like tell fart jokes if you
want
i'd rather get drunk and just have a
good time before we get to that
[ __ ] but you said something that i want
you to back up you said that the
democrats are trying i'm not
denying the possibility that this is the
case but this seems like if that was the
case it would be a
grand conspiracy that would at least
have you'd have to have some evidence of
this to make that statement
that they're trying or they want to
crash the economy
because they they want to to maintain
power
and to change censorship and to change
the way
there are okay we've had governor newsom
we've had governor
um cuomo whitmer cuomo
exactly all say the economy isn't going
to be open because trump's done a bad
job
we're not going to open it until he's
gone and then whitmer has even come out
but it's true wait a minute newsome has
openly said that
you sure yeah type it in i mean what do
you think
he said i've never i've listened i'm a
criticism i've i'm a critic of newsom
because of his uh this he's becoming an
autocrat he's just
his winery's open but there's a lot of
issues right there's a there's a lot of
issues so that
they they close so many things joe joe
joe
globalism was about selling america off
and bankrupting us under cloud
strategy fine but don't don't change the
subject i'm not
specifically what newsom has said
um you can pull it up just like i told
you about the atm what did he say
that you think and again i'm not a fan
of him
i'm a critic listen i i think you got to
give people grown adults
the choice if they just look we don't
have overrun hospitals we don't have
people dying in record numbers
we don't have five percent death rates
the cases and the deaths are increasing
that is true but as long as there's a
disease
they're going to increase the question
is at what rate
and the people that are dying there's
never many of them have never morbidity
factors
it's never about the death rate it's
always about increased infection
because the death rates weigh down right
now it is rejection
they're gonna say it's flu and alex the
cold they're gonna count
you get me again when when you say the
deaths increase
that is going to happen the question is
by what rate
and how many right you take the normal
and pneumonia and morbidity like they
did this year and you add that to the
number they've already run the same scam
and so whatever they don't count fluids
of death or pneumonia anymore they only
like they all kind of cove because they
get money on the chart
right they get 50 plus thousand dollars
when they call it a cove of death
plus when they say that they get 13 000
to say it's a covet patient
and they get uh 29 000 or whatever extra
when they intubate somebody
and so now since when is like congress
saying how to do medicine
well the isn't the idea that they're
doing this to give money to these
hospitals
to help them in the middle of a pandemic
yeah so these but then the hospitals
reasons code everything is covered to
get the money that's come out
they killed most people that died died
nursing homes or died from intimation
when it's an autoimmune event and you
don't want intubation
it's intubation that's killing you but
they initially thought you did but
that's why they're not because it was
responsible
thank god the numbers went down because
they stopped intimating yes so now it's
all about everyone's being before
there's this high death rate
because they were intubating and they
were counting and they were killing old
people
as soon as they stopped shipping folks
to old homes they weren't getting
vitamin d there's no sun
it went like this so so infections like
this
you pulled the grafts yeah you're like
what's your science pull it up and you
know
infections like this deaths like this
right well you're going up and down
right death down
now what did gavin newsom say though
that you when you said that he said it's
not going to get better until trump's
out of office
well it's it's whitmer that said that
specifically and he said cuomo because i
remember that too but he was just
basically like well
i want to be friends with trump there's
been a bad response we've got to keep
the lockdown going and
you know until trump does this wrong
until we have a change it's going to
continue on
and then it's always about the power
grab like oh it's two years we have to
do it no it's now it's
first it's 15 days to keep the hospitals
empty and then it's uh
then it's oh six months and now it's two
years and then gates said like a week
ago
it's ten years and now they've got the
the people
vouching and they're saying no it never
ends you never shake hands
and under the u.n rules they say don't
look at someone
and turn your head so in europe you can
type this in
uh citizens in the uk told do not look
at other people and turn your head it's
cult
programming man i think it's a pretty
common talking point and
some people agree with it like a lot of
democrats would say yeah it's not gonna
get better until trump is out because
trump has made a mess of it i don't
think trump's done the best yeah that's
what he said
but that's that's a common what could he
have done better
well done better he shut down flights
from china
in february when when pelosi's running
around in chinatown saying yeah but
i think it's a pretty common belief that
they're saying listen we so i don't
think it's a
conspiracy or i don't think like you
have to fight a source i think it's like
they believe if he wasn't in that it
won't get better until he's gone
so i don't think they actively are
trying to make it better
until he's gone exactly exactly they
want to keep the crisis going
i do see what you're saying i just want
to know if there's evidence i want to
know if there's an actual statement
where he said after when trump leaves
then we'll open back up that's well
that's actually what whitmer said
specifically but
he said some more things but well let's
find where we're going from memory here
i mean my god i understand
but that's why i'm challenging agreement
but i'm
challenge you on this because these are
people online
are going to want to challenge you on
this right so i want that's what they
loved about our last interview over a
year and a half ago
which they loved was that people could
go and actually check the stuff i was
saying
yeah no matter how crazy a lot of it is
true so i want to find that quote now
see if whitmer said that it won't get
better until trump's out of office
in terms of the lockdown yeah whitman
merchants whitmer lockdown won in until
trump's house
didn't she lose some court case recently
yes
her supreme court but also federal
courts have ruled
across the country that you can't order
churches to wear masks
you can't order social distancing it's
all just getting us to comply
don't you think it's a good idea to
encourage people to wear masks if
they're going into large gatherings a
lot of studies a lot of studies show
that doesn't even protect you listen
listen trump told the truth a few days
ago when he came out and he said
we're never going to control this we
have to learn herd immunity
or if you're really scared of a take a
vaccine and the head epidemiologist of
rockefeller
uh hospital came out and said that and
got banned on youtube i mean listen
italy did social distancing italy did
masks italy did everything you were
supposed to do
and they're getting clobbered again so
that makes me think that maybe it's not
a bad idea to do these things but they
don't seem to
they don't seem to believe that they
didn't second sweden didn't do any of it
and it's the lowest death rate in europe
right but it's also a
country of small villages they have a
whole different way of life over there
well i mean italy italy
is a bunch of three generations living
in one house yeah yeah
and and they have they're the oldest
people in europe yes so yeah and they
need to they need
sunlight they need they smoke they're
all good food try finding a gym over
there
they smoke every time i [ __ ] go there
it's hard to find a gym
they listen exactly they were rational
joe have a restaurant joe i came out
eight months ago and i and i and i was
selling this stuff but you get i said
get at the store
vitamin d vitamin c zinc and zinc
if you have that on the nih website it
can't
according to the nha nih website cannot
replicate inside the mitochondria
where the virus plugs into the cell and
makes it replicate okay
and so i just mean like jones claims
he's got a cure no it's not a cure
if you've got sunlight and zinc and and
vitamin c and all these things you need
it's
very hard to get these things that's why
it's old people in nursing homes that
have been outside in years
that are dying so easily now falci
finally two months ago came out and said
you need vitamin d you need vitamin c
that is true and young jamie takes
vitamin d and he kicked in a day
yes and vitamin c and zinc young jamie
was feeling bad for a day
but i don't want to argue joe i want to
just say i love bill gates
okay let i love i use windows i'm
looking for tell me
i can't find whitmer's quote specific
quote that says that
there's lots of quotes about them going
back and forth obviously because they've
had a public battle i just think anybody
like that whether it's bill gates or
bezos or anybody who's a billionaire if
they
say here's the suggested course of
action they have to expect that they're
going to be criticized and a lot of
these guys don't like
taking any criticism when they they're
issuing edicts
these are billionaires that are saying
this is how
we're going to live yeah that's the next
big question strange though that bill
gates who is not a health expert
is all of a sudden one of the leading
voices yes it's strange that's my
seriousness that's my next question yeah
why is bill gates who's not a doctor
suddenly on tv telling me
how my life's going to go and what i'm
going to do this is the most important
part why is this a
a big project for him well he's also a
guy that wanted to shoot a missile of
dust into the atmosphere to help climate
change i mean
very few people in history have had the
resources to even think of doing
something like that that's right he
wants to have jet spray
chemicals to block the sun right and the
scientists went
great no good they went not a good idea
so and then if you quite call him on
that if you call him on that he goes
the conspiracy lies and the conspiracy
theories it's like no we're just asking
you why you understand there's no
space he went on cbs news they go 80
of those taking your vaccine trial
getting very sick some are dying he's
like well that's just how it is
you can pull these clips up what yeah i
said that's just how it is
yeah he said well the fda is going to
approve it
he's beat red look at you you're
blending in with the walls
because but yeah it's a problem that's
hilarious
that's a problem it's a problem you know
i'm kind of [ __ ] this is
this is for two years they said trump
worked for i've heard of
political mudslinging my whole life for
two years
they said trump was an agent of russia
he was an asset of russia
the president then they did a whole
report and then it came out that he
wasn't there was no proof of it with the
cia the nfc everybody
and then they went like this he went
well we might have been wrong about that
i mean
it was mine disturbing things to me was
when ted cruz was cross-examining
comey when he was asking him questions
about what they did with evidence and
how they doctored evidence what do you
got jamie
oh i just can't believe that brian
redband is here he's he saved us
brian flew in when jamie tested positive
for cooties
and we've
so we had to have the protocol was you
have to be
uh ten days and you have to test
negative three days
before you come yeah brian's gonna move
here he's looking at houses right now
you are too
tim's gonna move i might you're moving
your [ __ ] i might come on sonic i know
i gotta i gotta i got some i gotta save
la first from the safest
it's not coming back that i know hey
let's talk about
not coming back please a little bit of
stuff yeah i don't wanna fight joe
we're not fighting no one's right
okay it's okay i love you no you did
this just have some
no i can't i can't i made a promise but
on election night i can pop yeah we're
gonna have
that's november third that's november
but i will be able to pop in six more
yeah
i have six more days of sobriety that's
gonna be a fight but i gotta
be honest i'm a little high from this
cigar hey you couldn't have a bigger
promo
for your election night i'm glad you
actually announced it here well
uh kyle kalinski's been asking when he
could announce it so now you know kyle
there you go it's official there you go
kyle i'm excited to get everybody in the
room
and watch this listen i want to cover
some of this real stuff here in real
time should i show you some stuff yeah
what do you got
do we ever find a quote for whitmer i
can't find anything i mean
there's lots of quotes but i can't find
that do you want me to find it
can you just google it on your phone tim
and i will talk amongst ourselves okay
and then we'll
then we'll pull up whatever that is okay
gretchen whitmer they almost kidnapped
her by the way
i don't have i'm just saying oh that's
whitmer when trump leaves office quote
she was almost there there was a
kidnapping plot against her
no it's whitmer which 15 percent won't
end until trump gone that's just come on
right lockdowns won't end till trump
gone try that
whatever i know it's true whitmer
lockdowns won't until trump gone he'll
find it
um yeah the plot to assassinate her what
the [ __ ] it was
like kidnapper that was weird but i
predicted up front that it was gonna be
fbi provocateurs and it turned out the
two leaders were fbi informants
what what's even crazier is 52 percent
of the citizens of michigan agreed with
the plot
that's a joke
[Laughter]
good one going to edit that part
where you say that's a joke joe rogan's
guess calls for kidnapping
this is outrageous d platform
when i went on alex's show alex goes
snopes always goes and finds like jokes
he makes it there go
they go oh correction hillary clinton is
not an oompa loop
did you guys see that um brett
weinstein's unity 2020 account was also
banned from twitter
just told me that his unity 2020 account
was which was calling for a third party
was calling for unity between people on
the right and the left
to get together and have conversations
and and perhaps even have a
an alternative candidate that's
outrageous well he's a [ __ ] scholar
and he's a guy who became famous because
he was a professor
at evergreen university and the leftists
took over the course and they said we're
going to shut it down and whites can't
come one day a month
they they had and then they banned him
yes well it
well just banned him they went looking
for him in the parking lot
baseball bats yeah it was terrifying so
let me ask you this the
the principal was going along with
everything literally they yelled the
principal don't
gesture with your hands because you're
threatening us but
he was talking like this
british universities like oxford i
think's the one look it up
oxford or cambridge one of the big ones
you can't clap
it's a microaggression joe oh that's so
crazy but this is what we were talking
about for years and people were saying
why are you concerned with what happens
in the universities
it's the same thing we were saying about
censorship because it [ __ ]
it keeps going it doesn't stop when you
when you allow that kind of nonsense in
universities
those kids graduate and they want to
carry these goofy [ __ ] practices
into all of these corporations
now that's one of the things i wrote
down i wanted to ask you joe and tim
dillon
what what happens how where do they stop
because they're going to keep running
until they hit opposition which is
starting to happen
how far does it go i was hoping there
was going to be some sort of a
federal regulation i was hoping that
trump was going to step in and they were
going to
amend the first amendment to include
social media because i think
what you're what you're seeing now the
the argument that these are just
just private corporations i don't think
that argument is valid anymore because
the impact that they have
the significance of being able to speak
or not being able to speak
to speak has massive implications on our
election
we see this with the new york post's
election meddling we see it with the new
york post being censored with this
hunter biden story
whether you agree with the story being
leaked or not the the fact that the new
york [ __ ] post
which is a legitimate newspaper as
outrageous as they are
and the fact that the [ __ ] white
house press secretary gets banned from
twitter
for for tweeting that link that's where
it is this is crazy i mean i think it
leads to
it's sadly at least the violence because
if you take everybody's ability to
communicate away there's nothing left to
do but commit acts of violence and by
the way that's a kennedy
quote those that make peaceful
revolutions maybe found something this
is as close as i could get to what was
what he's asking for to be found okay
the trump virus response is the worst in
the globe she said
if you're tired of the of lockdowns or
you're tired of wearing masks or
you wish you were in church this morning
or watching college football or your
kids were getting
in-person instruction it's time for a
change in this country
and that's why we've got to elect joe
biden i mean that's pretty
that's why i mean you you can make that
say whatever you want almost
yeah but that's the common sense right
right the problem is the problem is if
you
just take it from if you're tired of
lockdowns
and you you get one you would get one in
interpretation of it but if you back it
up to
the trump virus response is the worst in
the globe
she said if you're tired of lockdowns so
what she's
saying i think we're splitting here you
mean you're not necessarily
because what she's saying i saw a clip
of her and please saying that
because that's the problem with taking
something out of context what she's
saying is
a wonderful person no i'm not saying
that what she's saying is that trump has
done such a shitty job
that's the reason why we're locked down
you can't go i get it they'll get it the
headline i don't know if that's true
though
i think when you've got a contagious
disease you got people flying in from
europe and china
and all these other countries that are
expressing you you're go
you're going to have spread this is a
[ __ ] insanely contagious disease
joe one of my favorite parts of your
show is when you
ask jamie for something then the light
turns on when you're looking at it let
me ask you this
you're in the numerator hammered are you
right now on scale one time at all we're
into numerology this is when it gets
good
you better okay
let's talk just be nice to me joe
i have to be nice to you got me here and
i know you are let's get serious
everybody wants to hear what i actually
have to say
okay what was the question you had me on
9 11 yes 12 5 55 now
one five five five yeah don't connect
the dots just i'm in town it's random
well you told me you were good at 9 11
on purpose yeah that was on purpose
yeah it was just fun but this is nothing
bad but
but this is see do you understand how
this quote you could interpret that
in a different way like i think the
entire
democratic party strategy i understand
to say trump is to blame for covet
and to say the economy shut down till
you get them elected that's what she's
saying
they're all good they're all saying i
understand it's like we're gonna end
this
by endless lockdowns once trump's out if
you want to go back to normal do this
and their own listen this is an end of
civilization event
the rockefellers and others put out
operation lockstep they're never going
to stop this they're going to have
coveted tracking they're going to have
checkpoints they're going to have
apps on your phone so how do we stop
this what trump came out and did and
said
we cannot defeat this with vaccines
and with covet tracking with shutdowns
it's going to have to be with uh herd
immunity
which is what the scientist actually
brought why can't we beat it with what
he beat it with he's 74 and he eats
french fries every day
this [ __ ] kicked it in four days
that's why that's supposed to be a death
sentence
if you've got vitamin d vitamin c and
zinc it's very hard to get okay
but clearly he's got more than vitamin d
vitamin c and zinc he's got a bunch of
medical treatments
right well he was given regeneron he was
driven things that are expensive and
probably not widely available but wait a
minute jamie
tested positive he's right over there
like timmy's young and viral
but i'm saying where since since when
did something come along
civilization is over civilization is
over
because of this thing that came out of
china you're not even supposed to come
you want to ask where cove it came from
i'm going to ask where it is do you feel
better about the disease
now that you kicked it so quickly uh
i mean how old are you at first how old
are you 37. first i was a little worried
for the first day i was like
oh [ __ ] here we go are we going down
like a two week three week four weeks
then a letter time
months right because you've talked to
people on the show that have been [ __ ]
up
sure yeah how lucky am i going to be
today is all right i was thinking that
and she's like so taking all the
vitamins
i mean we got yeah i got all that we had
nad and all that stuff too in my system
yeah
like i don't maybe that helped i'm sure
hopefully sure did of course
statistically they said five percent of
us will be dead it's not even
well they thought point one percent okay
but what they thought they're the
all-powerful gods it's like the u.n says
you will not question us big tux says
you will not question
anything the u.n says meanwhile the
union's like oh we shouldn't do a
lockdown it's killing millions of people
starvation
but still it's like worse keeping the
lockdown going the united nations said
well what do you think should be done i
mean i think we should look at something
that isn't much worse than the flu and
say we all need
natural vitamins and nutraceuticals and
sunlight
and health and people should just know
they got to deal with the way it is
because
we always get diseases we always get
viruses we always live with
the idea we got to lock society down and
go into our houses and
this is a post-industrial move
that they're using to roll out these
systems to keep us locked down in our
homes right and if you want to be
cynical this is where you step in and
say the reason why they want us to be
upset and they want the economy to be
[ __ ] is because they hate the
president and they want him out of
office and they want to regain power
they want the democrats the american
economy the
in the image of what they want they want
to remake a lot of these these um
systems that they feel are for whatever
reason
uh they just injust or unjust or
whatever and they want to use this
opportunity to kind of
redraw the lines exactly after 9 11.
exactly
this is the new 911. the u.n and and the
davos group all say
this is the post-industrial world the
great reset i got a copy of it for
right here and they say in these
documents
we are going to reorganize society code
that is good to shut down the carbon
carbon is bad
we're going to end success we're going
to end prosperity
we're going to track everybody we're
going to control their lives all under
the name of covet they said all that
they said we're going to end success
we're going to end prosperity
uh yeah in the lockstep the rockefeller
document 2010 they say
we'll have a viral release or a
simulated one that creates total fear
while bringing a police state
marshall is this available for someone
to read absolutely wasn't there
something called agenda 21 or something
where they were saying we want people
living in cities we don't want home
ownership
compact cities yeah yeah and you were
saying it earlier they go oh
it's for the greater good that we don't
have cars anymore it's for the greater
good
we have donald trump that's what i was
saying what i was doing was give playing
devils
you were quoting them yeah what i was
saying you said that joe you believe in
that i was saying that autonomy i do
believe in cars too
autonomous vehicles are in the future
at least likely to be safer than people
just driving and texting well it's not
safe given
control over these corporations and
robots and making ourselves obsolete we
need to build a pro human future
well i'm pro-human but i know you aren't
saying you're not joe feller thing from
sounds a weird
i was already looking this up as he
mentioned it because i was going down my
own little rabbit hole
it says when i first started to find it
my first search just says there's a
small
a large conspiracy has been built out of
this small grain of truth from this
document from 2010.
okay that's what it starts to say so i
haven't oh is that snopes small
grain of truth yeah so snow systems like
god it's like i don't think is it snopes
that you google
let's focus on the grain of truth no who
says it's a grain of truth
hold on no no it's operation lockstep
and it says a global police state will
be brought in from a pandemic
and there'll be worldwide martial law it
actually says it in the document
okay it's like they always go like oh
there's no hunter emails the
emails are real right i love that clock
it is weird that they're saying
tgg studios is it is weird there's a
document okay
the rockefeller foundation annual report
2010.
i'll control f what would you like me to
look up
uh look up uh police state look up there
just look at police state
don't forget the exact words i mean
let's just go read it for yourself
control f police station came up this is
just one paper that's it i mean that's
the whole pdf is here it's like it's
real really really long
so when you control st f police state
nothing
okay what else uh i i mean i've got i've
read it before it says that so
anybody can read it right now so you
think they edited it no
no it's i mean i can't remember exact
words okay well let's look up pandemic
look up pandemic
pandemic just means widely distributed
epidemic means you're actually sick
four mentions of the word pandemic okay
all right with no network to
transfer critical infectious disease
information without open lines of
communications
thousands more fall sick the new in
quotes disease
becomes an unchecked pandemic by the
time the
the right expertise is brought to bear
on the world government it's
too late the disease has spread around
the globe in a world of global trade and
travel what's traded faster and travels
furthest
are the microbes in every handshake
southeast so what do they what is this
in reference to okay it says a few miles
east young boy has been hold on don't
please go back to that
yeah just it's just it's just a scenario
that they're painting
so make that a little larger no no go
back to it
just go back to where it was all right
the potential pandemic of the few
decades have severely tested the world's
ability
to work across human borders detection
remains weak in many parts of the world
the public health response has
frequently been slow and fragmented
the looming threat of infectious disease
presents humanity with a new challenge
to communicate and collaborate swifter
and with greater efficiency than ever
before that doesn't sound like they're
trying to end the world okay well you're
just reading one of these documents i
already i can pull up the articles i can
show you yourself
but this is world government controlled
they talk about a worldwide police state
you search the term pandemic i'm telling
you what's in these things
okay uh emerging pandemics the new
century sars
avion flu and swine flu if we don't move
investigated systems of bringing global
warming it seems like they're trying to
prevent
pandemics if we don't move quickly
viruses will
uh by continuing our drive to invest in
systems that coordinate efforts and
share information
the rockefeller foundation is working
together which is the global government
controlling all of us
to meet the health challenges of an
interconnected world
is it the perfect analogy terrorism
because it's like terrorism exists
people want to prevent terrorism but
it's like
how many rights do you give up in order
to do that and then
you know all these proactive measures
that we take to prevent terrorism a lot
of them create more terrorists who
i think it's like a balance of like be
remaining a free society and dealing
with a lot of these men listen i sit
here
you know we sit and we talk about
something and then whether jaime can
find it or not becomes the arbiter
whether it's real
so they found something about an att
lobby they didn't find a thing about
this
i've got the operation lockstep
documents where they say
we're going to bring in this global
authority but you have to
then you have to show us those well i
mean i i'm sitting here in studio
talking to you about this but i
understand i understand that's almost
what you're saying but we we wanted to
try to know everybody else watching this
is gonna go look it up well i hope they
do they're gonna go crazy
i hope we wish we could have found it
right then if it's real no no no i know
you want to show it but it might be
an interpretation of what they're saying
like the whitmer now it says
specifically
the whitmer quote is just a criticism of
trump she's been
blaming all this lock no whitmer was
found by the
by the supreme court of michigan and by
a federal court to have seized all three
branches of governments
and basically set up martial law they
even used those terms he was overturned
saying that quote i i want to when you
say if you are sick of lockdown
yeah and you're sick of not being able
to go to church joe biden should be
elected
agree that is not a huge jump from what
he said no it's not a huge jump yeah but
the problem is
the way it's being said she was talking
about how bad
trump handled the the rate of infection
first
of course and that's let's expand on
that i remember like interviewing lou
dobbs like 15 years ago
back when he was still on cnn we were
looking at documents
where it said we're going to bring in
global government the north american
union using
the threat of viruses migration flows
and economic collapse
and they said like a deadly flu or a
deadly sars yeah i'm sitting here
watching this power grab
watching the u.n and and and big tech
saying well you can't say
that that the un's wrong because the
un's in charge since when is the news
wh and all these doctors all these
medical doctors that come out and say
other things
other than them like how steroids cured
it or you know how hydroxychloroquine
helped it
how are they being banned even if they
were wrong
they should be have their license
removed that's what that's about it's
not
google decides that if something isn't
that you and it's taken down that's all
i'm saying
well it is a problem that they're
deciding which doctors to listen to and
which doctors not to
when there is some real controversy as
to how to
handle the virus virus with treatment
right what treatment
is effective and what isn't effective
now it turns out there's a lot of
doctors that think that
hydroxychloroquine
isn't effective there's a lot of there's
some doctors that thought it was and
they think that the
combination of zinc and hydro but the
ques the the problem is the people
that are deciding what gets taken down
or not getting that's a huge taken down
and the problem is that the doctors
would go well we think you know it's
like
there's we we've minimized the voices of
the people that
are saying one thing right and we've
elevated the voices of the people that
are saying another thing and it's like
that becomes the real issue whether
people like trump there's there's
stuff to criticize about trump we all
know that and there but in their defense
they're doing it because they think that
people are going to do something foolish
they're going to go out and spread the
virus further because it's not the
media's job
though to this is the problem i think
the media has taken on this really
activist role
where they are now there worse it's not
the meters social media
social media companies not not even
necessarily the media
where you have like legitimate
journalists that are talking do you
think he would do something in a second
term about social media
i think he certainly is going to do
something why hasn't he done something
already
because it's so complex because they'll
claim it's election meddling even though
they're doing that at the same time
what we have is multinational
corporations acting in tandem
that are already making the nation state
obsolete they're creating a
information warfare monopoly and they're
censoring people and using that power
they have
and we just sit here denying it's going
on until it's too late
i mean it's it's it's a really serious
situation and it is crazy it is a crazy
situation where all of these tech
companies
all lean left all of them yeah they do
they lean left and they support like
there's there's no tech companies are
out there supporting donald trump
there's no tech companies what's very
interesting because tech companies are
very wealthy people right
they're insanely wealthy but david
pakman had a really good point about
that
that they like when it comes to their
financial dealings they
they're very conservative very
libertarian and conservative oh they
don't pay taxes
right i mean google pays almost taxes
what i'm telling you does apple complain
about chinese slave factories in china
no it's what i'm telling you is it's all
bs and when you study
what they're doing i can sit on my phone
and pull it up they talk about in
lockstep
bringing in a global authoritarian
system they talk about riots they talk
about war
if you can find that article there
aren't messages
i found something but i don't i'm trying
to understand what it's saying because
it's now it's
like it's speaking about years in the
future as though they've already
happened well we're not too far away
from let's see because like they're
painting another scenario just like they
painted
with that uh infection scenario
archive.org i found
i went to the second page of this link
but this is like scenario
narratives it says lockstep it talks
about uh pandemics from 2012 and the
sars and all sorts of
h1n1 so i skipped into the next page
just to
while you guys were talking and this is
the part that that's a little strange
which
is getting into what i think he is now
where is that can you highlight um
it started here because it says about
kenya in 2025 and people being weary of
top down okay
by 2025 people seem to be growing weary
of so much top down control and letting
leaders and
authorities make choices for them
whatever net wherever national interest
clashed with individual interests
there was conflict sporadic pushback
becomes increasingly organized and
coordinated
as disaffected youth and people who have
seen their status and opportunities slip
away
largely in developing countries and
cited civil unrest
by 2026 protesters in nigeria brought
down the government
fed up with the entrenched cronyism and
corruption
even those who'd like the greater
stability and predictability
of this world began to grow
uncomfortable and constrained by so many
tight rules
and by the strictness of national
boundaries the feeling lingered
that sooner or later something would
have inevitably upset
the neat order that the world's
governments had worked so hard to
establish
okay i never read that but that's the
other stuff it's in there i'm telling
thousands of pages man okay it talks
about global police state and
worldwide riots and i mean we're not
that far away there's people are saying
they're writing that yeah they're
they're writing it almost like i've
like the eu right it's a supernational
financial architecture
people are saying that borders are
racist people are saying that the idea
of america is races their countries
you know israel the idea of a country or
nation state is racist there is this
growing
uh idea or ideology that
global governance is a good thing or
that nation states are
you know well it comes down to this it's
not that nation of states are perfect
multinational corporations
are bigger and operate in many cases
more powerfully than governments
correct and so they want control and
they say they want control
and they're going to use racial
differences between two countries to
play them off against each other and
they're going to use
global crises to centralize global
control and that's what they say in
these white papers is
the corporations are using this for
global control and there will be
rebellions against it that's what i read
and then people
more loyalty to multinational
corporations and more loyalty
they have more in common with people
that live in london or davos or switzer
than they do to their american citizens
and that
that becomes the problem you've got
google and facebook executives on jumbo
jets and mansions
telling us we've got to lower our carbon
footprint and be poor they're hypocrites
it doesn't hold water
yeah how do we get out of it there it is
authoritarian capitalism
i mean i remember i i don't have it in
front of me but i was reading the
lockstep rockefeller documents and they
predicted worldwide police state
uh authoritarianism civil war i mean
they're predicting in 2018
says will africa embrace were africa's
embrace of authoritarian capitalism a la
china continue and then vietnam
to require a solar panel at every home
in 2022
and then in 2025 that's not the same
documents i saw but
that's the question is it's weird the
way they're writing this
they're they're writing this as this
they're they're predicting already
happening
yeah well they're they're talking about
it like they're they're seeing the
future and
like almost like it's fiction but
they're talking about it like here's
trump saying
we're not gonna control the pandemic you
don't you get used to it you get over it
you fight it with nutraceuticals you
fight it with you know with with
therapeutics it's
the idea that bill gates came out two
weeks ago and he goes we'll be shut down
for 10 years
is that what he said he said yeah he
said this goes on for 10 years
until there's not one corona case well
they pick the perfect
the perfect problem they can never do it
isn't that crazy like
you see a guy like jamie who literally
kicked it in a day and they're saying
we're going to close down
the world for 10 days well it's also
like the war on terror is still going on
i mean yeah they want to
exactly they want a problem that never
goes away yeah it's never gonna i mean
the cold war went on forever i mean this
is just
they like these things but we've entered
into three hours in here two and a half
hours in here we've entered into this
weird spot we're like okay what could be
where you're going to drink whiskey yeah
i don't know i've already been about at
election night i'm here
what could be done um what can be done
man all i know is i try to tell the
truth i make mistakes but i'm sitting
here
with these notes i've written where i
read what globalists say
i gave you that wall street journal
article where they go we're in we're
impure that we can get sick
it's time to get rid of all humans and
merge with machines it's so beautiful i
think well that's just one kook
and then it's almost all these people
and really they're trying to convince
the public to all roll over and die
but wait a minute isn't that a
provocative article
by a journalist who's trying to paint a
rosy picture of our
symbiotic relationship with technology i
mean when someone's saying
like i mean literally saying looking
forward to the end of humanity that's
it's a provocative article it's like but
that's the nihilistic attitude these
people actually pick up i mean yes it is
but it's also sort of this inevitable if
you
extrapolate from where we are now with
technology to where we're going to be in
20 30 years
and when you look at things like neural
link and you look at a lot of this uh
technology that they're they're coming
up with but we're talking about big tech
censoring us i don't want them plugged
into my goddamn brain yeah
it's probably a bad idea it seems like a
bad idea to have them invade your body
well when you're talking about
centralized power like that
it is not a good idea it's a bad idea to
give them all i'm saying is
joe and i'm glad you're here i'm glad
you're here i'm very excited to be here
tonight and i really appreciate you
we have to get people to debate the fact
that there's people
engineers and technocrats choosing their
course
and that the public is not involved in
deciding that course
i hope people are starting to understand
when you see the white house press
secretary
get banned from twitter when you see the
new york post links get banned from
twitter
i hope people are starting to understand
that giving people power giving large
groups power
over whether it's national discourse
whether it's policy any of these
these things yeah it's bad it's a bad
idea it's a bad idea
exactly you don't want to do it the
founding fathers although they didn't
predict
technology they didn't predict the
internet they did predict what happens
when you give human beings ultimate
power
right i mean power corrupts absolute
power crops absolutely yeah
so joe you just said it so let me ask
this question
because see this you got a huge audience
we could really change the world right
now i think we've done a good no one's
listening
no they're listening there's no one if
you want to change the world you go on
alyssa milano's show
that's the show dude no no i only get
three times as many listeners
people that are zombies don't don't
matter i'm sorry about what you mean
i'm sure she won't take zombies but let
me tell you that i don't think zombies
did you guys hear what i said
listen you can look at tony podesta or
john podesta and laugh at them they run
the democratic party
it came out two months ago in the new
york times bragging that they were in
the meeting
when they were wargaming on thousands of
people listening on a telephone call
they go we're not gonna concede and
we're gonna
have the country break up and we're
going to have secession
and we're going to call for the u.n to
invade america how [ __ ] up would it be
if you
like all this stuff actually comes
through the way this happens this will
be [ __ ] insane
is it good but when people are talking
about
be careful with that that camera don't
bump that camera but i'm not
saying it's going to happen i'm saying
they're saying it because if it doesn't
happen i'll be glad
but they're like oh you know jones is
saying this is happening no i know you
will be grabbed
they're literally this
like this podcast can be heavily
criticized right we are aware of this
but when we knew that coming in but when
this goes down if this goes down the way
you're describing it
how eerie would this be well i don't i
it would be very
eerie it would be very scary because
somebody will tell you like this is what
they're saying they're going to do
now i hope they don't do it but they are
saying
that they're going to contest the
election when they lose and if trump
tries to declare it
big tech has implemented this ai system
that's going to block
hundreds of millions of americans from
being able to say
trump won election night yeah and so
that's why election night is so
spectacular and some people can say well
there's never been voter fraud before or
voter fraud has been so minuscule in the
past
that is true but however the ability to
vote by mail
in advance never really existed like it
existed exactly and 80 million ballots
put out there
80 million ballots put out there's a
total wild card so who is counting all
these ballots
it's the locals it's whoever grabs them
it's whoever puts in the false names
there's been a bunch of people arrested
right but if you're say if you're in a
democratically controlled state
and you so who is controlling and
counting
those those ballots
brian redman he's a good guy he'll tell
us the truth
brian get over here real quick he's
going for two minutes
okay we need brian no
i mean seriously i don't know what's
going to happen joe
i know the democrat chief strategist
says we're going to contest the election
we're going to break the country up like
civil war 1862
and we're going to do all this and we're
going to say that go ahead they found
water on the moon
awesome
they did find waterloo you know six
months before they said that
buzz aldrin called me up and he said
there's water in the moon and he goes we
they're going to crash an end in probe
and there it's like not you know 2007 or
something
they're going to crash an indian probe
on the moon i want you to know we
already crashed while they're going to
find the water i was like thank you buzz
aldrin
so he called you up yep does buzz call
you often
no he's called me like three times are
you ever shocked are you like
he's like it's alex's puzzle he actually
got like 20 million views before they
took it off youtube
he was on the show one time and he goes
my secretary really likes you
on here he goes is she a hottie you're
lucky i'm doing this i'm like
well yes sir he goes there is the moon
of
mars that is where the real obelisk here
is 2001
and the aliens created the pyramids and
i just wanted to tell you alex you gotta
what
he said the aliens created the pyramids
yeah and there was an obelisk
that's not as shocking the the buzz buzz
aldrin said the aliens created the
pyramids
yeah i'm telling you i was contacted by
buzz aldrin's secretary
and i'm not picking this up this is real
i don't believe you are
and and it's just like whatever this was
like 12 years ago whatever 10 years ago
whatever it was
like hey buzz aldrin wants to come on so
we checked his buzz aldrin he wants to
talk about his new book
and once he gets on he goes it is the
soul moon
choron or whatever it's called look up
the moon of moon of
i'm off memory of somebody get this
stuff wrong of mars he goes that is
where the true obelisk is and that will
give us the data tapes to
go the next level and and i just wanted
you to know that because you're a good
person that
the pyramids were created by aliens and
we're doing important work there he is
buzz aldrin admits aliens built the
pyramids
and the phobos monument oh the the uh
he said after he talked to me on c-span
yeah and so
he said aliens built the pyramids i
swear
to god this guy really went off to
reservation like you think nasa is like
doing a better vetting process now
because this guy really well you know
he's had tough times
well he just endorsed trump oh did he
why did he endorse trump all the
military endorsed trump all the police
but listen i'm not bragging i don't know
why
i thought he had him on about a book he
wrote he starts telling me about aliens
the pyramids and the french let me ask
you this what did you think about the
pentagon saying recently that they've
recovered crafts that are not of this
world
i think it's probably true i think it's
probably true as well i think we're like
to ditch
like a movie theater but i talked to uh
stuff of the ditch like
yeah when i talked to commander fravor
um who is the guy who saw that uh the
tic tac
ufo off the coast of san diego the way
he describes it and the the video
footage that they got of this thing
and his his take on it is [ __ ]
chilling
yeah that thing went from 60 000 feet
above tic tac
okay yeah it looks like a tic-tac-toe
new code name it's tic-tac-toe
no no yeah it's a huge problem no it's
just a little tic-tac-toe
what do you say about it he said that
this thing went from 60 000 feet above
sea level to one inside of a second
he said it defied propulsion
by any but any understanding that we
have of physics the way it moved
was insane it was actively blocking
tracking systems
which is an act of war they do they
block all the radars
you could listen to him on my podcast
but i would actually recommend you
listen to him
on lex friedman's podcast it's available
on youtube and lex does an amazing job
of of
talking to him and breaking down let's
do that what do you think the universe
is what do you think
let's talk real what's the secret
universe totally legit report says buzz
aldrin saw aliens when he was up in
space
sarcasm oh well that's not joe is that
you in the photo they said that he tried
they reached out to his people and they
said that this bogus and we don't know
where it came from
it's bogus we don't know where well he
came on my show and said that
the pyramid thing the pyramid quote and
said it's bogus yeah well maybe they
pulled them aside but joe let's get
let's have fun here
everybody's watching it's an epic
podcast part three joe rogan
i want to know so what is what what do
you think runs the universe what do you
think the secret is who are the dmt
elves
when's the last time you took dmt it's
been a couple years um
i don't think that there is
any doubt that there's other life out
there it's a matter of uh
if it contacts us regularly whether or
not it's contacted us or why it comes
and why it visits or
uh jacques valet i believe i think his
perception is not that they're from
another planet but that
that would be probably the least
spectacular answer
and that they could be interdimensional
travelers some people believe that their
time
jack valet is the guy who uh steven
spielsberg
he modeled that french scientist in
close encounters with the third kind
after him he's a really really
interesting guy and that's what i
personally believe is
interdimensional it could be that it
could be that
our understanding of reality itself is
very limited it's like
you know if you wave your hand above
certain insects they have no idea you're
even there right
they lack the ability to detect it that
we we have senses that we assume
are the only senses that are available
and it is entirely
likely that there are many dimensions
that we don't have access to
right and this is the quantum physicists
and all those guys that write the [ __ ]
on yellow
legal pads that you don't understand
they they all believe there's
many many dimensions out there there's
no jobs i agree with you i agree with
you
i think the universe is insanely huge
and they're finding life compatible
planets
on a daily basis there's hundreds of
them now so i agree with you let me ask
this question then what do we do about
this corrupt political elite
trying to make us look at them we'll
follow them how do we break free of them
well that's a different thing of the
universe but my question is like why are
they telling us
now that they've acquired these ships or
that they they
they have access to these things or that
they know these things are real
you know um bob lazar has basically been
describing exactly that
in exactly the same way since 1989
when uh when he was uh
first hiding uh when he was on uh
george knapp's television show in vegas
and they had him out only as a
silhouette
and then he eventually came out and said
that he was a propulsion expert that was
brought to area s4
and they've tried to discredit him and
they've tried to talk but
one of the things that he said was he
talked about element 115
and that this was something that they
used to propel these crafts and it was
something that
it can it could change gravity can bend
gravity and propel itself
in a way that is not like any propulsion
system that we use now which essentially
you have to push something out the back
to make it go forward whether it's
flames or
you know a rocket or anything else like
even a an airplane right
it propels things forward and what he
was saying is that
what this element 115 is allowing them
to do is to somehow or another
bend space and time some another bend
gravity
but they don't know how it works they
don't know
what what it's doing let's talk about
this operates on this element
let's talk about this hold on they know
it operates on this element it was only
theoretical until
i think it was 2013 or 2015
they used a particle collider and they
they they
detected it in an actual element 115
that it was actually real and that's
what the superconducting super colliders
are for
well i mean they're they're for
detecting many things
well these particle colliders are for
detecting many different things that are
theoretical
and they they find these things to be
true and then it becomes you know
a scientific record what i think is that
we are apes we are these weird
talking apes that are at an adolescent
stage of technological evolution
and what we might be looking at when we
see these these
uh tic tac ufos and other things we
might be looking at something from the
future
we might be looking at time travelers we
might might be looking at something that
comes back
and you know i think that's i think
that's a good approximation but
we're a little bit beyond just apes
clearly we're from outside the planet
and there's something bigger going on
like this this life forms happened
before
this is a major test and so we can sit
there and just say oh we're just apes
no i don't mean that what i mean by
we're just apes is that in comparison to
what we could be eventually through
evolution
you're saying metamorphosis yeah we're
we're on a
look we're a lot smarter than apes right
than regular apes that are in most of us
in in the zoo yeah or in well some of
them's dumber than that yeah right yeah
i was about to say
some of them are dumber paint with a
broad brush but we are nowhere near
where our potential lies right right our
potential lies far far
far in advance of what we are currently
and i think some of this has to do
with some of these uh symbiotic
technologies that we're talking about
like neurolink and a lot of these things
that are are being proposed that are
eventually going to
find their way into the human body and
accelerate but
are they going to lower our ability are
they going to censor our ability
well because we're already growing and
all i see from big tech is censorship so
is the neural link
gonna censor what i do well the little
plug-in and make me feel great and
hit my pleasure center when you're
talking about human emotions
and greed and power and all these
different things these are all
biological issues that we have that the
idea is
will be transcended if you could somehow
if you believe the big tech lords aren't
like us
they're they're us though so they're in
charge of the same thing that we already
are
so to say oh big tech lords are going to
take us away from our human problems
right but do you want to transcend sin
they're going to make it worse okay but
do you understand that they didn't
understand what technology was going to
create when it created the internet
the the ability to totally establish
the ability to distribute information
that existed pre-1990 whatever when the
internet became
mainstream it was very very very
different than it is today and it's very
hard to get away with the things you get
away with in the early
1980s what they wait what they can do
now in terms of a regular person
and their ability to transmit
information to access information
it's all what i'm saying is
giant leaps i get it the technology's
there i'm not against the technology
it's those that introduce it to us and
then control how it's deployed
i understand that's a big issue but
everything is about what i was trying to
get to is
the way information has gotten out of
their hands and you can distribute it in
a way that they never anticipated
if they did anticipate it i guarantee
they would have never left the internet
i agree i used to
i think that same thing is going to
happen with all other technologies
and if that's the case technology may be
our only hope
technology may be the only thing that
saves us from
all these human emotions the the need
for power and greed
and control the the one thing that might
save us
from that is this symbiotic relationship
with technology
where we connect to things that will
alleviate a lot of the
problems that you know if that
technology i don't i'm not saying this
is good or bad
or wrong can i say something yeah you're
doing really good this is
great rants best joe rogan i've ever
seen i'm not being patronizing it's good
stuff it's okay you're drunk
no no i'm saying this is powerful be
nice
be nice what i'm saying is
there's outside groups trying to program
that so you can't project your own
goodness
onto this not saying even goodness i'm
saying no i'm what i'm saying is you've
been
ranting for five minutes and i'm i'm
just what do you just say
i get what you're saying it's just that
you're sitting there saying this will
free us from our problems
but it's still humans that program the
nexus points of it
so it could actually amplify the
problems i'm saying we should be wary of
all
oh it certainly could look it could go
sideways it could all go bad
but it also could go to a point where
people don't feel the need to do that
anymore
and that we recognize that a lot of what
we have is
we we are escaping the shackles of our
monkey bodies
our monkey bodies yeah so if we're
silicon
and have don't need resources anymore we
can just be spiritual
and then we'll be able to free ourselves
and not hurt the earth anymore hop in
that tic tac
and fly to alpha centauri in the blink
of an eye so we need to we need to uh
no i already see the transmission if you
could have a spaceship that would allow
you
to go anywhere in the galaxy would you
be willing to give
up any of your emotions for that no i
know that i know that i know the digital
deal
give up your body for the silicon gods
and become a god
this is all fun and games but like we're
not even i mean california we're not
even allowed to go to applebee's so
let's stop with the spaceship
let's just try to get i'm not allowed to
leave my phone i want to go to the
comedy store
yeah i mean we'll get a spaceship
eventually let's get a few
got your thing i'm coming to your
election night you're drowning with me
election night elections 25 billion
listen you invited yourself to this i
think you should settle down aliens
you told me already no you invited
yourself we already got it
coming no i said you could come in for a
little bit but you're you're making it
the alex jones show
no i'm not it's a bit of an issue this
is like the elections there's an issue
applejack of an issue settle down it's a
bit of an issue it's gonna be a fun uh
fun experience it'll be a lot of fun
but what being so mean you you literally
might be me no i think joe wants to beat
my ass friend no i don't listen alex i
love you
but what i'm saying and i'm not even
disagreeing with you i'm saying that
i think when you were talking about
aliens and we're talking about life
forms from out of space and space travel
and [ __ ]
the biggest big issues of the election
well you see those [ __ ] things like
the
ceremonies they all have big heads yeah
they're crazy little
tiny muscleless bodies heads shaved
heads yeah they're
kidding like they escaped they've
escaped all of the you're actually an
alien
they look like what we're gonna be yeah
but who wants to be that
i don't want to be that right i mean
that's what i'm saying no i'm with you i
like being a person
right i think we should be humans for as
long as we can what do you think aliens
are
there are all sorts of interdimensional
forces in the universe in
multi-dimension so there's like bad
aliens that are trying to
manipulate our development gretchen
because a high level
exactly a high level would not try to
manipulate our development
right okay so so joe is like imprinting
on these demons because he loves him
he's a bad person no no seriously
so all i'm saying is is we need to build
towards the next level
and do amazing things what do you think
of the what do you think and i did
invite myself
on the election show it's gonna be great
i got on my news in front of joe that's
correct i'll do it again right now but
what do you think
of my name stop making it about you no
it is about me i'm i'm front of goodness
you're drunk
i want to come on yes ban you from
alcohol what i want
you're going to smoke weed with me what
do you think about we're going to i will
definitely do that
what do you think the highest rate of
everyday what do you think about the
theory that human beings are the product
of accelerated evolution that they came
down here and they genetically
manipulated
lower hominids and they created human
beings listen i already have the genetic
memory i already told you all this
i mean already you have a genetic memory
yes that's epigenetics
yeah okay so i have a genetic you have a
genetic memory
right i have a genetic memory and i have
genetic memories that weren't you know i
have a bunch of memories
so you go watch star wars like i've done
this before this looks totally normal
we're in the universe we're in the
planets we're here our lives forms have
been all over the place like little
seeds that
jump from planet to planet like blowing
to the space winds so yeah we've already
been here before
because this is one of the things that
lazar brought up that they discussed
with him at area s4 they said that
they believed that human beings are the
product of accelerated evolution it's
like
and he wasn't sure if they were [ __ ]
with him like when he was reading all
that stuff he's like is this like
disinformation no they weren't [ __ ]
with them
yeah i mean but
god doesn't know where god came from
whoa and we said that last time that's
heavy and we don't know where we came
from right
but we have the archetypal memories that
go so far
and then our big fear is have an
evolutionary death of the species
it's like a line of you know flowers or
plants or you know whatever we are and
it's it's a whole
genetic experience we're conscious
individuals but then we have a genetic
experience
that goes on forever as long as the
light of the genetic experience doesn't
die
so we're always looking for eternal life
as long as we keep having kids they have
kids we live forever
that's us we just get better well as
long as the earth doesn't experience a
massive extinction event
but that's what i'm saying before you go
interplanetary that's well so the main
mission number third
79 days 79 days of chaos and i am
endorsing joe biden right now
i'm voting for by the way that might be
a good strategy if you endorse joe biden
right now
i'm going to go with my history of
voting for people that have been on the
podcast so i'm going to vote for kanye
i'm going with joe jorgensen because i
like to back a winner am i sitting in
the same seat as kanye yes you are
all right i'm fulfilled that's the best
all right but before this goes any
further off the rails i think we're good
we've done it oh you want to end this
transmission do you i never got to all
my
notes you got more [ __ ] what else would
you like to talk about i got more [ __ ]
than you can [ __ ] imagine here
come back you got to come back november
3rd when you're going to have guys
wheeling no settings
just wheeling objections joe said he's
like you're the one inviting yourself
november 3rd
oh you're coming you certainly did i
waited like uh he was invited here so 19
months or something
alex if i showed you the list of people
that are trying to get on this [ __ ]
show it would make your head spin i know
but i live down the street i understand
i don't care you don't want me 30
minutes on election night we're gonna be
fine we're gonna be fine
but i'm just saying i survived without
it it's very difficult for me to
manage a [ __ ] small fraction of the
number of people that are trying to get
on
well this is an epic podcast we've only
we got to go another hour
it this is gonna be
bigger than the elon musk that's the uh
i'm gonna say that doesn't have to be me
i'm the second biggest podcast
you can't be compelled every listener
has to spread this link right now or i'm
gonna die
well youtube no i wrote notes for you
let me read these notes to you yes
please do please okay okay what's
important
major goals to accomplish how the
president could
invoke martial law you handed this to me
i don't even know he did like
a magic trick yeah the sudden this is
just my hands i don't even remember
getting here i don't remember be happier
these are big
important topics do you drive around
with this just in the car
no he's actually done research to
prepare for this show know a lot of the
research and then i was like i'm not
going to drink i'm going to be good
and we're already here i'm going to talk
about heavy i just wish this was six
days from now so i could be how many
hours are we into this we're three hours
in or three am yeah if we don't break
the last record we're going down what's
the last record no we don't have to
break records no
tim dillon you rant why get ready
give us your latest comedy
i love joe like it's true uh i was like
literally on me he's like a joke can i
please come under an election listen
we're going to go somewhere he said yes
he like slapped me he goes we're good he
punched me the nose he goes i didn't do
that and i grabbed him
none of that happened but but tell me go
over your notes and
tim and i'll talk is this everything
that you hoped it would be this is my
version of a make-a-wish kid
going to disney world this is the
greatest thing i've ever done is to sit
here
i've watched alex since i'm 13 years old
uh
pre-911 when he was ranting about the
wto and
i followed him through 911 through
bohemian grove all the big events of my
childhood
and uh just this big to be here can i
say i'm very impressed with your
knowledge
like you know a lot of this stuff well
you i didn't go to college you have a
lot of time
there's a lot of time if you don't go to
college you can i'm self-educated
yeah well yeah there's a lot of
information yeah the important stuff
disposal
yeah you got some notes i like how your
new studio is like
like a colon listen this new studio came
together in just a few weeks we
really didn't know what to do i had this
room we banged it out real quick but
this is going to be known as the colon
um people call it the rental yeah that's
a radio right here oh my god this is the
red pill he called it the red pepper so
this is a very rare studio
you're getting a new one ready i know
yeah we're well we're having problems
finding a good location but yeah
we'll have how about my house
[Laughter]
i got a huge area
we're going to find a good spot it's
amazing we're looking right now we're in
the process all right let's get serious
okay oh i covered a lot of this
alex we're good man we're good no yeah
we have to go another two hours
i'm going to see you again in a week
i am on the night like this relax
at the back how about i just back you
don't act come on man
i'm not below is there anything else you
really want to discuss
no i mean i'm glad that jamie is better
than i am but search the internet i'm
not kissing his ass but
i'm really good at it he's better than i
am which is almost no one knows
he does it with one hand the problem is
i remember all this stuff now most of
the time it's accurate sometimes it's
not
but i mean if i'm saying something i
believe i saw it or i did it one thing
that was in there
i didn't want to correct earlier but uh
the year you were talking about
something
you kept saying 1963 and then they went
to like 82 or whatever that happened
on 73. that the group wasn't even around
yet the
the something to roam clubber room yeah
that was that wasn't even created so 68
so just for clarification purposes okay
cool
i think they had a subgroup earlier than
that
i'm not saying you're wrong yeah well
who knows but jamie's com i mean he has
george soros covent this is a
compromised individual might have
compromised the the records
oh that's another thing i want to say
can i say yeah
this is the most important thing we said
tonight we said a lot of important
things
but both of you are not drinking yes so
you don't know
right but this is it right now okay
mrna vaccines yeah so when you think
about a regular vaccine
goes in it's a broken bacteria a broken
virus it's defeated
your body learns how to kick its ass
it's like a dummy it's like
an attack dog training on a dummy right
the t lymphocyte
white blood cell it's like a big badass
mike tyson
it learns how to defeat it mrna vaccines
go
into your cells as a virus they're
viruses
so it's a virus they inject you with
that reprograms your cell
to then have a certain response to
things and release proteins
which is what cancer does and so they
admit on the news that 100 of people
that take these are getting sick
20 are going to um the hospital
and so they also have vaccines that are
called behavior modification vaccines
you can type it in okay but let me pause
right there
mrna vaccines you said 100 of them get
sick and 20 of them go to the hospital
they had two studies uh in one study 100
got sick 20 with the hospital another
study 80 percent got sick and of those
20 percent went with the hospital that's
cbs news
jamie's going to find that right now you
type in bill gates grilled
over over vaccine dangers you know cbs
reporting
but the point is they admit a bunch of
vaccine deaths have happened now
from the test but what was i going to do
before then you were just talking about
mrna oh behavioral yeah behavioral
modification
yeah so type in vaccine to cure heroin
addiction
but we're going to get to that but
before we get to that we got to google
the stats on mrna vaccines because that
this is going to be highly contested so
we have to find out well no you can time
i'm not going to show you the clip
bill gates but we just googled the stats
on mrna uh
patients in the trial i don't even i
think they don't have a stats on that
so how do you know it bill gates was on
cbs news
and he said 80 of the people get sick
yeah
and 20 percent of them go to the
hospital no it was two vaccines they
said one vaccine 100
got sick and a certain percent went to
the hospital
the other 80 got sick and 20 of those
and sometimes that does happen even the
flu vaccine right like sometimes people
get
i swear to god you type in bill gates
grilled by cbs i'll bring it up
right certain vaccines do get people a
little we had that conversation with the
whole thing in india you know he
introduced a lot of vaccines in india
there was some
negative reactions to them i mean that's
what happens it's just
you know a lot of people so i sent you
the article
at mrna vaccines i sent you the article
about
um ap about the majority of new
polio cases are the bill gates vaccine
you went
we'll get to that too let me see if
jamie can find this
mrna thing um
you know you don't have a morton's next
door here m-r-n-a
i'm going to look it up and i'm like are
we going to go
he's making a point about vaccines and
now we're at stake i am not hammered at
all
i've been drinking orange juice you
polished off a half a bottle of orange
juice
um a job just so you have fun i'm happy
you're here
legitimately um so
if you can't find that the behavioral
modification what is it you want to find
bill gates polio vaccine
causes of polio ap ap
ap dot com uh
the headline the exact headline is why
does everybody hate bill gates what is
going on because he's so sexy
i i don't think people hate him
no it was like it was it was like
ap uh you bill gates did not say
seven hundred thousand people of
negative side effects he did say that
my god he said it on he said it on nbc
news
bill gates did not say 700 000 people
have negative side effects from a
coronavirus vaccine i have the video of
that okay but
pull up ap bill gates polio vaccine
but that's a coronavirus uh he said
polio vaccine
all right okay now now i'm pissed i'm
going to tell you the headline it was uh
we'll see if there's a polio hold on
what was headline article
it was uh u.n
u.n vaccine causes polio u.n vaccine
causes polio okay
u.n vaccine causes polio google
google is compromised can you just ask
jesus please
un says new polio outbreak in sudan was
caused by oral vaccine
yeah whoa it's not good new polio
outbreak in sudan is caused by
oral vaccine and this look at that kid's
face
oh my god is that a terrifying image the
image of them distributing that look at
that
poor kid's face imagine that kid getting
polio from that vaccine
just he looks so terrified oh my god
yeah i mean that's tragic oh
then a bunch of them died but you know
jesus christ alex jones
hold on hold on back up back up back up
back up
what does it say up there it said world
health organization says a new polio
outbreak in sudan is linked to an
ongoing vaccine-sparked
epidemic in chad a week after the u.s
vaccine
sparked epidemic health agency declared
the african continent free of the
wild polio vaccine world health
organization said it found 11 additional
vaccine-derived
polio cases in sudan and that the virus
had been identified in environmental
samples
there are typically many more unreported
cases for every confirmed polio patient
the highly infectious disease can spread
quickly in contaminated water
and most often strikes children under
five [ __ ]
jesus christ in rare instances the live
polio virus
in the oral vaccine can mutate in a form
capable of sparking new outbreaks so let
me tell you a story
my grandmother died three years ago at
92.
incredible woman that's [ __ ] terrible
she was told by her doctor
in 1954 when she got the second polio
shot they said sorry it was live
it paralyzed her she was on crutches
rest for life they told her it didn't
turn
jesus christ so see i just told you that
yeah it's true and that's a whitewash
what ap is doing
i would imagine so i'm telling you i
make mistakes because i can't remember
all this stuff i understand you remember
a lot
but i'm not trying to lie i wish the
last thing i want to say is this
i'd like to retire the next year i'd
like to finish up my work
clean up mistakes i made talk about
other stuff
because i'm in the diet of a heart
attack or going crazy i'd do this 18
hours a day
i like to get you in shape i'm totally
stressed out joe i'm done i know you are
i know
i literally do this stuff constantly i i
read thousands of articles i know you do
if i text you at three o'clock in the
morning you respond right back you're
wide awake well i'm not a victim i'm
telling you i'm dying i understand so
i can't do this much longer and i want
everybody to know i love my crew but i
told them i can't keep running this
operation
i just want to tell the truth and i want
to get out the next year doesn't mean i
won't go on your show once a year do
like a write a book or something but i
want you to get healthy
i need to get older i try to get healthy
why don't you hire a trainer and hire a
dietitian
i try because i know you got off the
booze for quite a while and
we were talking you said you felt great
i did feel great i lost like 40 pounds
how long did you get off the booze for
four months no alcohol about eight
months and barely any
like the last three or four hours right
back but you you you were talking to me
about adderall
the problem you know i want you to talk
about that because that's a good thing
for people to hear
the the the problems that you had with
adderall because that [ __ ] scares the
[ __ ] out of me well i'm not gonna get
any of that type of stuff
the point is is that it's is that the
things that doctors push the things that
go on
the whole country's drugged up on a
bunch of stuff yeah and uh
it's it's it's not good but i'm not i do
caffeine and alcohol that's it
and and it's all very very destructive
and you know
it gets to the point where like you're
exhausted unless you drink
and it's not a good thing that's why i'm
glad you sober in october last october i
was sober
yeah um do you think you could
just kick it totally i mean you kicked
it for four months
do you think it'd be if i wasn't doing a
show every day and having to read i mean
i'm not exaggerating i read
50 articles i probably scanned a 500 i
mean i
look at so much stuff that it's just
it's enslaving me like i
i just want to i don't want to be around
it anymore
it's not like i'm scared of it i'm just
i want to be something else it's
negative it has negative consequences in
your health
yeah so so for me i just want to get
away from all of it
and what do you want to do i'd love to
go hunting fishing and
relaxing and oil painting and doing
sculpture i love metal sculpture
i love that that's a beautiful
chimpanzee skull guy right there i mean
i just i've done this 26 27 years
and when you've done it that long you
want to stand the fight at the same time
you want to not do it anymore
and that's the thing about people the
democrats suing me and attacking me
before trump even got elected i was
already telling people i'm gonna shut
this company down
i can't fund all of you i can't do this
anymore them attacking me
made me keep fighting do you think that
if if you were healthier if you
maybe just did less
you you could be all right with it
i didn't do that as a stunt i'm in quite
honest with you i'm a smart i'm a smart
i think i'm going to die of a heart
attack at like 50 something i'm 47 now
and i just i just have to like there's
no way to do this
full-time either you do it or you turn
loose
and i'd like to just for a few years
just disappear so you think that
the amount of [ __ ] that's out there and
when and this is a problem with
conspiracies right because you keep
finding more and more and more that are
provable
and you start going crazy because you
start
really exactly and you lose who you
exactly like yeah i don't like the
globalist i'm not giving in to them i'm
giving in to like my own body
i understand it's not like their attacks
keep me fighting them
like they keep thinking like oh this
mess with me more he'll give up that
makes me like attack more
it's and i'm trying to like get him to
top attacking me it's not some
machiavellian thing i'm saying
i just want to like i don't want to be i
don't want to look at the news
maybe if he just took some time off and
like
it just got healthy maybe maybe maybe
that's what you need maybe you just need
a
extended vacation i mean you're your own
boss
right you could do that do you ever
think you maybe shrink the operation
down a little bit
and then you can kind of do what you
want how you want
you know instead of instead of just
being a 24-hour day
operation you could just take it down
well here's my problem when you get
personal
i mean i had perfect teeth till like two
years ago i have to wear a
mouth brace because i'll literally crush
my teeth when i'm asleep
like i broke one just the other day i
got implants going in right here
and i'm just like literally in my sleep
clenching my teeth so hard
that i've got like giant muscles like
i'm not arnold schwarzenegger but my
jaws
are right like they're like look like a
chipmunk and it's because that's
psychologically i'm trying to defeat all
this
and it's just like it's like a certain
point i can't do it all right
so i don't feel sorry for myself you've
earned it you've earned some time off
yeah why don't you just take take some
months off just
like mark an extended hiatus you know
whenever you feel like you could get
away and just
decide you're going to take three months
off put the [ __ ] cell phone down
eat healthy exercise you mean you could
hire a trainer
you know not a bad idea there's nothing
i want to do more than that
because you know what i'm doing the
sober october thing and when i've
done it in the past one of the things
we've done is these fitness challenges
you don't even realize what you can do
until you're forced to do something
if you force yourself like say hey for
the month of uh
january i'm not gonna drink and i'm
gonna exercise every day
and i'm gonna put it up on you know my
website and let everybody know what i'm
doing and
and just force yourself to to try to get
healthy
only eat healthy food and maybe get a
dietitian
maybe get a trainer not even maybe get a
dietitian get a trainer
get someone who makes you uh like meal
preps for you
gives you a healthy food to eat and this
is all you're going to eat is this stuff
no
no processed [ __ ] just healthy food
wouldn't be a bad idea just take a whole
month
and do nothing but that just leave the
[ __ ] news alone let this crazy world
sort itself out
no i agree because now i look at news
and it's just like you still like oh i
got them right here on the speaker
i was like now almost like oh my god
yeah because you're probably overrun
you know it's probably taxed out your
body's probably like barely hanging in
there
i mean if you're boozing a lot and
you're not getting sleep and you're
grinding your teeth
none of these are good signs
i'll be honest about the listeners but
you know at the end of the day
like this is fundamental this is an
anti-human movement
it's a globalist movement and i get
people that are doing it are sociopaths
that have created cosmology
to explain why they're doing all these
evil things i just i feel like it's such
an important mission
that it should be exposed and joe i'm
just glad you moved to austin
i'm glad that tim's here tim's moving he
just told me
i got to save la first and then i want
to go work with bill and melinda gates
for a while and then i will come to
austin you can't save la
i know i know we'll see november 3rd
so joe what is your prediction who wins
who wins in six days
i'm not smart enough to make the
prediction but i trump's gonna win i
think it's going to be chaos
either way it's gonna be chaos i think
of trump i've never
ever in my life felt this country more
divided
it feels more divided now than i've ever
felt before
where the the possibility of a civil war
doesn't seem
outside the realm of of possibilities it
doesn't seem like something ridiculous
it doesn't like people used to say if
they said it in the past someone said
oh this country is on the brink of a
civil war 10 years ago i'd be like
listen this crazy [ __ ]
but you say it now and i go like i could
see it
tim why are you not moving to texas well
i i might advance
this i might eventually i don't know
we're gonna see i gotta move
i gotta open a car joe convinced me that
joe told me to move to la a year ago
and then i moved and it just destroyed
so tell me to move here i might move
here it'll be a problem we're going to
start a comedy club out here yeah
we're going to set this place up right
well thank you for having me
my pleasure appreciate it but i
appreciate you being here with
everything else i hope that would be
good this is a great one alex i think
people got to see a side of you
that they maybe even didn't see in the
other two podcasts
you know i think you you did a great
account of yourself and
i think really you think so yeah yeah a
lot of the [ __ ] that you brought up
today was
i mean you were pulling [ __ ] off the top
of your head and
a lot of it was accurate a good solid
percentage i'm not trying to [ __ ]
no you're not trying to [ __ ] no i
know you're not and this is what i've
always told people about you
and and again i think that
we're at a critical time where we've got
to rethink
all these people that are calling for
people to be censored and calling for
people to be de-platform and i think you
got to rethink this
i think everybody has to rethink this
because you you might be looking back on
this 10 years from now
and going oh my god what the [ __ ] did i
support but i agree with you but we
should
you're being nice to the sensors they're
tyrants
we should hear everybody's views i think
there's a lot of people
in this in this machine and a lot of
these people they're not tyrants they
think they're doing good
they really do i think there's a lot of
people that are out there calling for
people to be
de-platform calling for people to be
censored because maybe they have
children
they see their children being
indoctrinated into q and on or all this
kind of
ridiculous thinking and maybe they they
think that the way to
to fight some of this [ __ ] is to just
take that stuff offline so the kids have
no no access
that only makes their children want it
more well not only that it makes the
people that
believe that there's a conspiracy to
silence the truth it makes them
even more fervent in their beliefs they
they start believing it even
more rabidly and not only that it it it
it creates echo chambers
and then this positive you are happy you
move to texas i [ __ ] love it here i
love the people i love the i love the
town
i love everything about it i do but
that's the good news
yeah and tim dillon yeah you come here
lower taxes good people
we want all the people from other parts
of the country food good food
food is amazing yeah there's a lot of
great stuff and the kids here are in the
q a
which i think that's good all of
children should be well they get
tattooed
when they're in the fifth grade listen i
love you alex jones
thanks for being here i love you tim
dillon thank you for having me being
here thank you guys
we did it we did it we did it all right
we did three and a half hours uh
something like that yes
and forward to infinity and beyond
band.video don't visit it
video bye everybody thank you
[Applause]
[Music]